I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello. Hey there. We have an exciting episode today. Better climb on the bus and get started. It's work bus season nine, episode four, written by Brent Forrester and directed by Brian Cranston.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。嘿。我们今天有一集精彩的节目。最好上车开始吧。这是工作巴士第九季第四集，由布伦特·福雷斯特编剧，布莱恩·克兰斯顿执导。
Yeah. The Brian Cranston. I mean, we were all so excited. We have a lot to share about that. We sure do. It's going to spill into next week. Oh, yeah. Two work bus pleasures. What?
没错。就是那个布莱恩·克兰斯顿。我的意思是，我们当时都超级兴奋。我们有很多关于这方面的分享。我们当然有。这还要延续到下周呢。哦，是的。两份工作巴士的快乐。什么？
I don't know. That's not it. Whatever. It's two weeks of work bus goodness. Because there's a lot to say. Yes. Let's start with a summary. It's a good place to start.
我不知道。不是那个。随便吧。这是两周的工作巴士福利。因为有太多话要说了。是的。让我们从摘要开始。这是一个好的起点。
Here it is. It always is. It always is. Jim tricks Dwight into believing the building is unsafe in order to give Pam a break you know Jim's feeling guilty. I'm speaking so cool so I have a whole thing I have a whole thing I'll save it go on I was not going to rant about it this is gonna give everyone a break well I did a little digging into. going to rant about it this week. I was going to give everyone a break. Well, I did a little digging into it. Anyway, I'm saving it.
就是这样。一贯如此。一贯如此。吉姆捉弄德怀特，让他相信大楼不安全，从而让帕姆休息一下，你知道吉姆心怀愧疚。我说话太酷了，所以我有一整套想法，我有一整套想法，我先留着，继续吧，我本来不想发牢骚的，这会让大家休息一下，好吧，我稍微挖掘了一下。发牢骚本周。我本来想让大家休息一下。好吧，我稍微挖掘了一下。不管怎样，我先留着。
Go. All right. Well, Jim's plan is thwarted when Dwight rents a bus for everyone to work from. Then Jim gets the bus moving with a promise of pie in an attempt to give Pam the best day ever. Nelly is going to seek a recommendation from Andy for an adoption application.
继续。好吧。嗯，吉姆的计划落空了，因为德怀特租了一辆巴士让大家在上面工作。然后吉姆以馅饼为承诺让巴士动了起来，试图给帕姆最好的一天。内莉要向安迪寻求领养申请的推荐信。
If you had any feelings of goodwill toward Andy, they will be completely squashed today, I believe. Yeah. This episode makes him fairly unredeemable. And finally, Dwight has a heart to heart with Jim. This is very off topic, but when you said thwarted, it sounded so funny. Why?
如果你对安迪有任何好感，我坚信今天它们将彻底粉碎。是的。这一集让他变得相当不可救药。最后，德怀特和吉姆推心置腹地谈了谈。这有点跑题了，但当你用“阻挠”这个词时，听起来太搞笑了。为什么？
I don't know, I just, I wasn't expecting you to say thwarted. It's not a word I throw out very often. And when you said it, I don't know, it got me tickled. It's one of my favorite words. Say it. Thwarted. I don't know, I think I use it a lot. Do a lot of my plans get thwarted?
我不知道，我只是，我没料到你会说“阻挠”。这不是我经常随口说出的词。当你说了之后，我不知道，把我逗乐了。这是我最喜欢的词之一。说出来。阻挠。不知道，我觉得我经常用。我的计划是不是经常受阻？
We have been best friends for a long time. I would never say, you know what, what of Jenna's favorite words is thwarted? I feel like I use it all the time in parenting because parenting is just like best laid plans, but then everything gets thwarted and you have to. Maybe you say thwarted a lot to Lee. I'm gonna ask him.
我们做挚友已经很久了。我绝不会说，你知道吗，珍娜最喜欢的词之一是阻挠？我觉得我在育儿过程中经常用它，因为育儿就像是最好的计划，但随后一切都被阻挠了，你不得不。也许你经常对李说“阻挠”。我要问问他。
You know what you say a lot to me? What? In particular. I say in ask him. You know what you say a lot to me? What? In particular. I say in particular? Mm-hmm. In particular. Really? Yeah.
你知道你经常对我说什么吗？什么？特别地。我说“特别地”。你知道你经常对我说什么吗？什么？特别地。我说“特别地”吗？嗯哼。特别地。真的吗？是的。
Not thwarted. Something to think about. Something to think about. Fast fact number one. Fast fact number one, it was during this episode that the cast learned that season nine would be our last season. Yes, we shared about this in our book, The Office BFFs,
不是阻挠。值得思考。值得思考。第一条趣味冷知识。第一条趣味冷知识，正是在拍摄这一集期间，演员们得知第九季将是我们的最后一季。是的，我们在书《办公室闺蜜》中分享过这个，
but I'll never forget it. It's such a clear memory for me. We were sitting in the bus, it was in the parking lot, we had all piled in there, and Greg came on the bus. And I wasn't expecting to see him that day. And he asked if it could just be the cast on the bus. And I wasn't expecting to see him that day. And he asked if it could just be the cast on the bus. And there was a few crew members that were kind of getting the bus ready for us to hit the open road. And they all left. And when he asked the crew
但我永远不会忘记。这对我来说是一个如此清晰的记忆。我们坐在巴士里，它停在停车场里，我们全都挤了进去，格雷格上了巴士。我没想到那天会见到他。他问能不能只有演员在巴士上。我没想到那天会见到他。他问能不能只有演员在巴士上。有几个剧组人员正在帮我们把巴士准备好，以便我们踏上开阔的道路。然后他们都离开了。当他问剧组人员
if they could step aside so he could just talk to the cast, I did. I felt like myself leave my body. I was like, Oh, I feel like this is when your parents are like, shut the door. We're going to have a big talk. Like, what? Yeah. Greg would do this sometimes. And usually he was going to tell us something like we'd been nominated for an award or we were adding a new big cast member or some news.
他们是否可以走到一边，以便他只和演员谈谈时，我照做了。我感觉自己的灵魂出窍了。我想，哦，我觉得这就像你父母说，把门关上。我们要进行一次长谈。就像，什么？是的。格雷格有时会这么做。通常他会告诉我们一些事情，比如我们获得了某个奖项的提名，或者我们要加入一个大的新演员阵容，或者一些消息。
It was news. It was always news. Yeah. But we weren't up for any awards at this point. Yeah. And we were like, the show has been cast for this year, so. What's this news? Yeah.
这是个消息。总是消息。是的。但在这一点上我们没有获得任何奖项的提名。是的。我们在想，今年的剧组已经选好了，所以。这是什么消息？是的。
And then he just explained to us that NBC was wanting to do maybe two more years of the show, but at that time, people's contracts were going to be expiring before then, and we might lose some of our cast. And then what was the show if it wasn't all of us, right? Yeah. He was like, do we want to call our own out and go out our way? Or do we want to slowly peter out losing cast members, right? Yeah. And we all collectively were like, we want to call our out. We want to go out together. I remember John Krasinski saying that this was such a great privilege to be able to call our own out. Because most of the time, if you're on a TV show, maybe you've taken your summer hiatus
然后他向我们解释说，全国广播公司（NBC）希望再做两年的剧集，但在那个时候，大家的合同在那之前就会到期，我们可能会失去一些演员。如果不是我们所有人，那这个剧算什么，对吧？是的。他说，我们是想自己决定退出并以我们的方式离开呢？还是想慢慢衰落并失去演员阵容，对吧？是的。我们一致决定，我们要自己决定退出。我们要一起离开。我记得约翰·卡拉辛斯基说，能够自己决定退出是一种莫大的荣幸。因为大多数时候，如果你在拍电视剧，也许你正经历暑期休假
and you're already, you think you're coming back for another year and you get a phone call that says, I'm sorry, the network's decided not to continue with your show. I mean, that's what happened with my ABC show splitting up together. We had this giant cliffhanger at the end of season two and all these plans for season three and just was over. And you get no goodbyes, you get no farewell moments. So the fact that starting from work bus, we knew, okay, this is our last season. And the writers could build towards that. And as a cast, we all, gosh, it was really bonding. Yeah.
而你已经，你以为你要回来再拍一年，然后你接到一个电话，说，很抱歉，电视网决定不继续制作你们的剧了。我的意思就是我的ABC剧集《分居》发生的情况。我们在第二季结尾有一个巨大的悬念，对第三季有各种计划，然后就结束了。你没有道别，没有告别时刻。所以从工作巴士开始，我们就知道，好吧，这是我们的最后一季。编剧们可以朝着这个目标创作。作为演员，我们所有人，天哪，这真的很有凝聚力。是的。
And Greg set a meeting with every single cast member and the writers and asked that cast member, what do you want to see for your character in this final season? And I remember Creed said, I'd like to sing one of my songs on the show. And I would like Devin to come back. He had stayed in touch with Devin ever since the beginning. Remember back in the Halloween episode, Michael has to decide if he's gonna fire Devin or Creed?
格雷格和每一个演员以及编剧都开了一次会，询问那个演员，你希望在这个最终季看到你的角色有什么样的结局。我记得克里德说，我想在剧里唱我的一首歌。我希望德文回来。自从一开始他就和德文保持着联系。还记得万圣节那一集吗，迈克尔必须决定是解雇德文还是克里德？
Yeah. And that's when Devin and Creed, who had been background performers, Creed ended up becoming a cast member and Devon moved on. He was going to do a play in New York. But Creed said, I want Devon to come back and I want to be able to play a song on the show. And we made both those things happen. But every cast member got to give their pitches for their characters goodbye. Yeah. Which is another truly classy move and very, very Greg Daniels.
是的。就在那时，德文和克里德，他们曾是背景演员，克里德最终成了演员阵容的一员，而德文则继续前行。他要去纽约出演一出戏。但克里德说，我希望德文回来，我希望能在节目里弹奏一首歌。我们把这两件事都实现了。但每个演员都得为自己角色的告别提出他们的想法。是的。这也是一个真正高水平的举动，非常非常符合格雷格·丹尼尔斯的风格。
I feel like the show started as a creative collaboration and it ends as one. 100%. So just to paint a picture for you at the beginning of this shoot for work bus, we found out that the show was coming to an end. We had a lot of feelings. We did. That brings me to Fast Fact number two, which is about how this episode
我觉得这部剧以创意合作开始，也以创意合作结束。百分之百。所以为了给你们还原一下画面，在拍摄工作巴士的初期，我们发现这部剧要走向尾声了。我们百感交集。确实如此。这让我想到了第二条趣味冷知识，它是关于这一集如何
also meant the end of our lives. Well, it sounds dramatic, but it is true that the whole entire cast, as you guys all know, because we've brought this up before, refers to this episode to this day as Jenna. Death Bus. That's right. We got a fan mail flurry about this,
也意味着我们生命的终结。嗯，听起来很戏剧性，但事实是整个剧组，正如你们大家所知，因为我们之前提到过，至今仍将这一集称为珍娜。死亡巴士。没错。我们收到了大量关于这个的粉丝来信，
Kindle W from Phoenix, Arizona, and many others said, Death Bus, we wanna hear all about it. Well, we wrote an entire chapter about this one episode in our book, The Office BFFs. Because number one, we had a lot of pictures from this episode. Thanks to you, Angela, you brought your camera on this shoot.
亚利桑那州菲尼克斯的肯德尔·W和其他许多人说，死亡巴士，我们想听听关于它的全部内容。好吧，我们在书《办公室闺蜜》中为这一集写了整整一个章节。因为第一，我们有很多这一集的照片。多亏了你，安吉拉，你这次拍摄带了相机。
I did, I was clicking away. So if you get our book, you're gonna see some great pictures, but also because three very significant things happened. First of all, Ellie Kemper peed her pants. She did. While we were shooting. She did.
我带了，我一直在咔嚓咔嚓地拍。所以如果你买我们的书，你会看到一些很棒的照片，而且还因为发生了三件非常重要的事情。首先，埃利·坎珀尿裤子了。她确实尿了。在我们拍摄的时候。她确实尿了。
Now, Ellie wrote about this in her book, The Squirrel Days. So we feel very comfortable sharing about it. And I reached out to Ellie and she sent in an audio clip with the whole story, which we will be sharing later. But besides Ellie peeing her pants, the entire cast of The Office almost died twice while shooting this episode. Yeah, two giant calamities.
现在，埃利在她的书《松鼠的日子》里写了这件事。所以我们觉得分享出来很自在。我联系了埃利，她发来了一段包含整个故事的音频剪辑，我们稍后会分享。但除了埃利尿裤子外，《办公室》的整个剧组在拍摄这一集时差点死了两次。是的，两场巨大的灾难。
Bridget S. from St. Louis, Missouri. How's it going there? How's it going, St. Louis? Is that what locals say they call it St. Louis? They don't. I just made it up. Oh, look. You're on the spot. Thank you for telling me because I could see myself going to St. Louis, being like,
密苏里州圣路易斯的布里奇特·S。那里怎么样？圣路易斯怎么样？当地人是这么叫它的吗，叫它圣路易斯？他们不这样叫。我刚编的。哦，看。你被问住了。谢谢你告诉我，因为我能想象自己去圣路易斯时会说，
what's up, St. Lou? You know what? Do it. Oh, no. OK. OK. What does Bridget say? Bridget said, is it true that Jenna's sense of smell saved the whole cast of the office
圣路易斯，最近怎么样？你知道吗？去吧。哦，不。好吧。好吧。布里奇特说什么？布里奇特说，珍娜的嗅觉救了整个《办公室》剧组，这是真的吗？
while aboard the work bus? Yes, Bridget. It's true. My nose did save the cast of the office. I'm very proud of this. Yep. But we will dive deep into all of these stories as we break down this episode. But we also got a lot of questions about the bus. Turner L from Stillwater, Minnesota said, how many days did you use the bus? Was there only one bus or more than one bus?
在工作巴士上？是的，布里奇特。这是真的。我的鼻子确实救了《办公室》剧组。我为此感到非常自豪。是的。但当我们剖析这一集时，我们会深入探讨所有这些故事。不过我们也收到了很多关于巴士的问题。明尼苏达州斯蒂尔沃特的特纳·L说，你们用了几天巴士？只有一辆巴士还是不止一辆？
Angela, I feel like Turner listened to our breakdown of speed. Oh, where we had the great debate of the 13 buses. Yeah. Yeah. Because Turner knew maybe there was more than one bus. That's a good question. Well, Steve Burgess said we only used one bus. We rented it for two weeks.
安吉拉，我觉得特纳听了我们对《生死时速》的剖析。哦，我们在那里对13辆巴士进行了激烈的辩论。是的。是的。因为特纳知道也许不止一辆巴士。这是一个好问题。好吧，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们只用了一辆巴士。我们租了两个星期。
We had to remove all of the original seats in the bus and put in the desks and the dividers. The description of how the bus should be laid out was pretty specific in the script. It noted that Andy should be in the back, that Erin should be at the front with a little reception area. It even noted that she should tape a candy dish to the front of the bus, so all those little details were scripted. And it even described who would be sitting next to who because this would be important for the different moments of dialogue. I found the sketch and drawing of the bus and where we were all seated in it. Oh my gosh. Yep. I don't know how it was in my digital clutter lady. I think they sent it to us with the script. you know? I think you're right. And I'll put it in stories. Look, that was with our script. Oh, yes.
我们不得不拆掉巴士上所有的原座椅，换上办公桌和隔板。剧本中对巴士布局的描述相当具体。它指出安迪应该在后面，艾琳应该在前面并有一个小接待区。它甚至指出她应该把一个糖果盘用胶带粘在巴士前面，所以所有这些小细节都是剧本写好的。它甚至描述了谁会坐在谁旁边，因为这对不同的对话时刻很重要。我找到了巴士的草图和图纸，以及我们当时在上面的座位安排。哦，天哪。是的。我不知道它怎么会在我的数字杂物堆里。我想他们是和剧本一起发给我们的，你知道吗？我觉得你说得对。我会把它发到快看里。看，那是和我们的脚本在一起的。哦，是的。
Now they moved us around. I feel like that was a rough outline because I was not seated next to you and in that picture I am. Yeah, this was an early draft because Daryl is on the bus here and Daryl doesn't end up being on the bus. That's right.
现在他们把我们的座位换了。我觉得那只是个粗略的大纲，因为我当时没挨着你坐，但在那张照片里我挨着。是的，这是早期草稿，因为达里尔当时在巴士上，而达里尔最后并没有上巴士。没错。
Yeah. What's interesting, I'm noticing in the sketch was when we read this, I immediately said, if this bus is gonna be moving, I'm gonna need to be facing forward. Yes, I remember that. And I remember there was like a little note in the script that even said Jenna will be facing forward.
有趣的是，我在草图里注意到，当我们读到这个时，我立刻说，如果这辆巴士要开动，我需要面向前方。是的，我记得。我记得剧本里有个小注，甚至说珍娜将面向前方。
If I would have ridden backwards, there would have been a fourth calamity, I would have ridden backwards, there would have been a fourth calamity, which would have been me vomiting on everybody. There's some really bad car sickness. There's one thing I wanted to point out in this sketch that I'm going to highlight in stories. On the bus sketch, there's in all caps, it says, note exclamation point, the AC unit above to be removed. They had to remove the AC unit to fit us all in there. That's gonna lead to some other issues later on.
如果我背向坐着，就会发生第四场灾难，我会背向坐着，发生第四场灾难，那就是我在每个人身上呕吐。这有点严重的晕车。草图里有一点我想指出，我会在快看里重点展示。在巴士草图上，全部是大写字母，写着，注意感叹号，上面要拆掉空调机组。他们不得不拆掉空调机组才能把我们所有人都塞进去。这稍后会导致一些其他问题。
It sure is. Let's see, so Steve also said we shot on the bus for two and a half days, which we knew. The half day was when we were parked in the parking lot. We weren't moving. Yeah. Then we had two days on the road or we were parked at the roadside attraction. I will have you know that all of the peeing and near death happened on the
确实如此。好吧，史蒂夫还说我们在巴士上拍了两天半，这是我们知道的。半天是我们停在停车场的时候。我们没有动。是的。然后我们在路上呆了两天，或者停在路边的景点。我要告诉你们的是，所有的尿裤子和死里逃生都发生在
final day of shooting. And Steve said after we finished shooting, they had to reassemble the bus to look like a bus and then return it. Those are all your bus facts. Okay, I liked them. Thank you. This is the second time we have had bus facts on this podcast. It might not be the last. I look forward to what that might be because I can't think of it, but- I don't know. Never say never.
拍摄的最后一天。史蒂夫说拍摄结束后，他们不得不重新组装巴士让它看起来像辆巴士，然后归还。这些就是你们所有的巴士冷知识。好吧，我很喜欢。谢谢。这是我们在本播客中第二次有巴士冷知识。可能不会是最后一次。我很期待那会是什么，因为我想不出来，但是——我不知道。永远不要说不可能。
Never say never on Office Ladies. All right, fast fact number three, Brian Cranston as director. We got a fan question from Cassie D in Portland, Maine who said, I need the all caps to know all about Brian Cranston directing. This was peak breaking bad days. So how did he come to direct this episode? What was it like working with him on set,
在《办公室女郎》里永远不要说不可能。好的，第三条趣味冷知识，布莱恩·克兰斯顿担任导演。我们收到了缅因州波特兰市卡茜·D的一个粉丝问题，她说，我需要全大写来了解布莱恩·克兰斯顿导演的一切。这是《绝命毒师》的巅峰时期。所以他是怎么来导演这一集的？在片场和他一起工作是什么感觉，
especially since the set was a literal bus? Were you as starstruck as I would have been in the scenario? Yes. Yes. All of it? Yes. Uh, yes. All of it. Yes. It was so amazing having him. He just like, man, talk about someone when he walks into a room, just commands the room.
特别是考虑到片场是一辆货真价实的巴士？你像我在这种情况下一样追星吗？是的。是的。全部都是吗？是的。呃，是的。全部都是。是的。有他在太棒了。他简直，天哪，说起当他走进一个房间时，简直就能掌控全场。
Yes. But in a very friendly way. Yes. Okay. It's like this gentle, amazing presence walks in and his voice and just immediately likable, Amazing presence walks in and his voice and immediately likable likeable and and just funny and doesn't take himself too seriously. You know like just someone that you feel like instantly you know and he's such a detail oriented actor. Yes, and so he has a passion and respect for acting so he brings that with him as a director as well. He was very interested in us and our characters and our process, but then he had this incredibly technical
是的。但以一种非常友好的方式。是的。好吧。就像那种温和、了不起的存在走进来，他的声音立刻讨人喜欢，了不起的存在走进来，他的声音立刻讨人喜欢，而且，而且很有趣，不会把自己看得太重。你知道，就像那种让你觉得瞬间就认识的人，而且他是一个如此注重细节的演员。是的，因此他保持着对表演的热情和尊重，所以作为导演他也把这一点带到了工作中。他对我们、我们的角色以及我们的过程非常感兴趣，但随后他还要完成作为导演的这项
job to do as director. And, you know, he had directed before. He had directed episodes of Malcolm in the Middle and Breaking Bad. And like Cassie said, this was peak Breaking Bad. This was between season four and season five of Breaking Bad, so yeah. And Cassie, guess what?
极其复杂的技术工作。而且，你知道，他以前导演过。他导演过《马尔科姆的一家》和《绝命毒师》的剧集。就像卡茜说的，这是《绝命毒师》的巅峰。这是《绝命毒师》第四季和第五季之间，所以是的。卡茜，你猜怎么着？
The best person to tell you about what it was like to have Brian on set is Brian Cranston, and he is gonna be with us next week. We have a whole interview with him about this episode. We're really gonna dive in, but he was just awesome. Just awesome. And that should tell you what a great guy he is when we reached out.
向你讲述在片场有布莱恩是什么体验的最佳人选就是布莱恩·克兰斯顿本人，他下周将和我们在一起。我们对他关于这一集的采访有一个完整的访谈。我们真的会深入探讨，但他真是太棒了。简直太棒了。当我们联系他时，这应该能告诉你他是一个多好的人。
He was like, yes, and I wanna come into the studio and see you face to face until all these stories. And he came in the studio, told us all the stories, and then just hung out. And we just like hung out and chatted for a bit about life. This rewatch podcast has reunited us with just the best people. The best people.
他当时说，好啊，我想去录音室见你们面谈，讲所有这些故事。他来到了录音室，给我们讲了所有的故事，然后就留下来闲逛。我们就那样闲逛，聊了一会儿生活。这个重温播客让我们与最棒的人重聚。最棒的人。
It's so great. We're so fortunate. We are really getting to relive all our glory. Yep. Well, Steve Burgess wanted me to add that Brian Cranston was very detail oriented during his prep week. He was a big part of setting up the bus.
太棒了。我们太幸运了。我们真的在重温我们所有的辉煌。是的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯想让我补充说，布莱恩·克兰斯顿在准备周期间非常注重细节。他是布置巴士的重要参与者。
He was very concerned with how tight a fit it was for the cast and the camera operators. The only people that could be on the bus were the cast, camera and Brian. Everybody else had to ride behind us in a follow van. Yeah. And that was, you know, a whole other consideration was that we had this caravan of crew
他非常关心对演员和摄像师来说空间有多挤。唯一能上巴士的是演员、摄像师和布莱恩。其他所有人都必须坐在我们后面的随行面包车里。是的。而且，你知道，另一个需要考虑的是，当我们开车时，我们有一支剧组车队的跟随
following us as we drove. The bus truly wasn't very big. I always think of it as like one of those smaller airport shuttle buses when you park in the far away parking lot. Not the big airport shuttle bus because there's the big one, but then there's the little guy that pulls up. Yeah, that's a good description. Well, we also reached out to our writer for this episode, Brent Forrester. He's always so fantastic about sending in behind-the-scenes details, and he shared with us about Brian directing and how focus Brian was on safety. Let's hear what Brent had to say about Brian directing. The irony of deathbuss is that Brian Cranston was so safety paranoid in the prep.
跟着我们。这辆巴士确实不是很大。我总是把它想象成那种较小的机场穿梭巴士，就是当你把车停在很远的停车场时坐的那种。不是那种大的机场穿梭巴士，因为有大的，但还有那种小家伙开过来。是的，这是一个很好的描述。好吧，我们还联系了这一集的编剧布伦特·福雷斯特。他在发送幕后细节方面总是那么棒，他跟我们分享了关于布莱恩的导演工作以及布莱恩对安全的关注。让我们听听布伦特对布莱恩执导是怎么说的。“死亡巴士”的讽刺之处在于，布莱恩·克兰斯顿在前期准备中对安全有着近乎偏执的关注。
He was just coming off breaking bad where they had been shooting in the desert in an RV. And he was so aware of what could go wrong. He would say, we're shooting on location in the heat in a tiny vehicle. Things can go very, very bad. And they did on death bus. in a tiny vehicle, things can go very, very bad. And they did on Death Bus. It is truly what we call this episode. I know. Everybody, cast and crew called it Death Bus.
他刚刚拍完《绝命毒师》，当时他们一直在沙漠里的房车里拍摄。他非常清楚可能会出什么问题。他会说，我们在酷暑中的外景地、在一辆极小的交通工具里拍摄。事情可能会变得非常非常糟糕。而“死亡巴士”上确实如此。在一个极小的交通工具里，事情可能会变得非常非常糟糕。而“死亡巴士”上确实如此。这真的是我们对这一集的称呼。我知道。每个人，演员和剧组都叫它“死亡巴士”。
And listen, we've all talked about this a lot as a cast and crew in our book with Brian that the irony that Brian was working on a show that filmed outside in the heat in an RV. And then he gets this job, woohoo, on the office. It's gonna be air conditioned. I'm gonna be inside in a cozy set. And it's the one episode where we are on the road
听着，我们作为演员和剧组在书中和布莱恩一起讨论过很多次这个讽刺：布莱恩当时正在拍摄一部在室外酷暑中、在房车里拍摄的剧。然后他得到了这份工作，太棒了，在《办公室》里。会有空调。我会在一个舒适的布景里。而这恰恰是我们正在路上拍摄的一集
in a bus in the heat. Yeah. And he did it on his week off from Breaking Bad. I know, that was supposed to be the week he got to be indoors.-conditioned. Oh my goodness Well, that's all I have for fast facts. Do we want to take a break? We do but before we go You should know the weather this week was gonna be in the 90s all week you guys I mean this episode started August 12th, and it was hot
在酷暑中的巴士里。是的。而且他是在他拍摄《绝命毒师》的调休周做这件事的。我知道，那本该是他能待在室内的一周。哦，天哪。好吧，我的趣味冷知识就这些。我们要休息一下吗？我们要休息，但在我们走之前，你们应该知道这周的天气整周都在90华氏度（约32度以上），伙计们，我的意思是这一集从8月12日开始拍摄，天气很热。
It was hot. There's my weather report. All right, we'll be right back. This episode starts, we're in a conference room, Andy is showing a highlight reel of the Dundermiflin softball team, except it's more of a blooper reel. And actually it's just Andy making fun of everyone.
很热。这就是我的天气预报。好的，我们马上回来。这一集开始时，我们在会议室里，安迪正在播放邓德米夫林垒球队的精彩集锦，不过与其说是精彩集锦，不如说是NG花絮集锦。实际上这只是安迪在取笑每个人。
They're not even bloopers. Well, this storyline, not the part with the fail videos that Andy shows, but just the softball league was loosely based on our very own Dundermifflin cast and crew softball league. I was not in it, but we talked with Claire about it. Yeah. I do want to point out that the videos that Andy are showing of the softball team, they're not fails. No one is failing. Like, he just says the word fail. Like, Darrell shares that was a triple and he's like, fail. I'm like, no, it's not a fail. Andy, these are not fails. Yeah. He manipulated the video and put like funny commentary fart noises.
它们甚至都不是NG。好吧，这个故事情节，不是安迪展示的失败视频那部分，而是垒球联赛，大致取材于我们自己的邓德米夫林剧组和演职人员垒球联赛。我不在里面，但我们和克莱尔聊过这件事。是的。我想指出的是，安迪展示的垒球队视频，并不是失败视频。没有人失败。比如，他只是说“失败”这个词。就像达里尔分享那是个三垒安打，而他说“失败”。我在想，不，这不是失败。安迪，这些都不是失败。是的。他篡改了视频，加入了有趣的评论放屁声。
Yes, exactly. But then Jim is like, Hey, what about that video I sent you? That's an actual fail. And Andy's like, Oh, I don't have a better. Yeah, I don't have an. And Jim's like, no, it's right here. And it is Andy trying to pick up the big Gatorade. What do you call that?
是的，绝对的。但接着吉姆说，嘿，我发给你的那个视频怎么样？那才是个真正的失败。安迪说，哦，我没有更好的。是的，我没有一个。吉姆说，不，就在这儿。那是安迪试图拿起大佳得乐水壶。你管那叫什么？
Jug, it's big. Cooler, it's a big cooler of Gatorade. You know, like when you win the big game and they dump it on the coach? Yeah. That thing. He picks it up and then he ends up falling with it and dumping it on himself.
大桶，很大。冷却器，那是个装佳得乐的大冷却器。你知道，就像你赢得大赛后把它倒在教练头上那样？是的。那个东西。他把它拿起来，结果自己摔倒了，把水全倒在了自己身上。
Well, Brent sent us in a clip about this, about how they filmed it and what a great sport Ed was. Here's what he had to say. We were quite pleased with that stunt in the cold open where Ed Helms falls down with the Gatorade. How we did it was we dug a hole in the ground, put a mattress in it, and then covered the mattress with sand. And it shows you what a go for it actor Ed Helms is.
布伦特给我们发了一段关于这个的视频剪辑，关于他们是如何拍摄的以及埃德是多么好的一个运动健将。这是他的说法。对于片头那个埃德·赫尔姆斯带着佳得乐摔倒的特技，我们相当满意。我们的做法是在地上挖了个洞，放了个床垫，然后用沙子盖住床垫。这表明埃德·赫尔姆斯是一位多么全力以赴的演员。
We had no rehearsal and no stuntman. And we just said, Ed, we need you to kind of trip backwards and spill on your shirt. Ed went for it so hard in the first take that Gatorade blasts out of the barrel and blows his hat off. That's the first take, and that's the one we used in the episode. I am so glad he shared that,
我们没有彩排，也没有替身。我们只是说，埃德，我们需要你向后绊倒，把水洒在衬衫上。埃德在第一次拍摄时就拼尽全力，佳得乐从桶里喷涌而出，把他的帽子都吹飞了。那是第一次拍摄，我们就在剧集里用了那条。我真高兴他分享了这个，
because when I watched that, I thought, how did that not hurt? So there was a mattress in the ground covered with dirt. I had no idea that's how they do that. Yeah. I can't believe after that take, they made him do another one. I know. Just call it a day.
因为当我看到那个时，我在想，这怎么会不疼呢？所以地上有个用土盖着的床垫。我完全不知道他们是这么拍的。是的。我真不敢相信拍完那条后，他们还让他拍第二条。我知道。就此收工吧。
We got it. For sure. Well, listen, I've got two tidbits for this cold open. The first is a quick location breakdown. We shot these scenes at the Balboa Sports Complex. The end. And? That's all I have to say about that.
我们拍到了。当然。听着，我有两个关于这个片头的花絮。第一个是快速的外景介绍。我们在巴尔博亚体育综合体拍摄了这些场景。结束。还有呢？这就是我要说的全部。
Next, second tidbit. Second tidbit is that I remember that these fail videos were very popular at the time. I mean, they're still very popular now, but I wanted to get more information on like the origins of fail videos. And in doing so, I ended up reading an article about the psychology of fail videos,
接下来，第二个花絮。第二个花絮是，我记得这些失败视频在当时非常受欢迎。我的意思是，它们现在仍然很受欢迎，但我想获得更多关于失败视频起源的信息。在此过程中，我最终读到了一篇关于失败视频心理学的文章，
and I thought that Dwight might like what I found. Not only Dwight, but you know who else would probably be interested is Zach Woods. Yes, you're right. So, because in our interview with him, we talked about videos like this. Yes. Well, I guess the Germans have a word to describe
我觉得德怀特可能会喜欢我的发现。不仅是德怀特，你知道还有谁可能会感兴趣吗，扎克·伍兹。是的，你说得对。因为在我们对他的采访中，我们谈到了这样的视频。是的。好吧，我想德国人有一个词来形容
the pleasure that we experience at the expense of other people's failures. Building Kinder? No, that's later. It is called Schadenfreude. Schadenfreude. Mm-hmm. It loosely translates as harm joy.
我们在别人失败的代价中所感到的快乐。Kinderbuilding？不，那是后来的。它叫幸灾乐祸（Schadenfreude）。幸灾乐祸。嗯哼。它的大致意思是“伤害的快乐”。
Wow. Psychologists believe that this is at the root of why we enjoy watching fail videos, and they've actually done a bunch of studies. This is fascinating. You know, like, people study everything. People study everything. People study everything. That's what I found out.
哇。心理学家认为，这是我们喜欢看失败视频的根源，他们实际上已经做了很多研究。这太迷人了。你知道，就像，人们研究一切。人们研究一切。人们研究一切。这就是我发现的。
Yeah. Well, that's what we found out doing this rewatch. But also, you know, when you think of like little kids like a toddler, if you want to make a toddler completely lose it laughing, pretend to trip and fall. Yes, they think it's hilarious. Yeah, it's in us from the beginning. Yeah. Well, let me tell you a scientist named Leah Boker, who was a researcher at University of Cologne's Social Cognition Center,
是的。嗯，这就是我们这次重温发现的。而且，你知道，当你想到像小孩子或学步儿童时，如果你想让一个学步儿童笑得前仰后合，假装绊倒摔跤。是的，他们觉得这太搞笑了。是的，这是我们与生俱来的。是的，让我告诉你，科隆大学社会认知中心的一位研究员、名叫莉亚·博克的科学家，
did an experiment taking- That's a tongue twister. It is a tongue twister. Leah took German soccer fans and had them watch videos of their biggest rival, who is the Dutch, the Dutch soccer team, missing penalty kicks. And she tracked their response. Then she showed them videos of the German team succeeding at penalty kicks. And what Leah found was that viewers were happier
做了一个实验，把——这真是个绕口令。确实是个绕口令。莉亚找来德国足球迷，让他们观看他们最大的死敌——荷兰队，荷兰足球队罚丢点球的视频。她追踪了他们的反应。然后她给他们看德国队罚进点球的视频。莉亚发现的是，观众更乐意
watching the Dutch team fail than they were watching their own team succeed. Whoa. Mm-hmm. Yeah, watching your rival fail makes you feel better than your own success was the takeaway. Well, jeez, Louise, that's kind of dark. Huh.
看荷兰队失败，而不是看他们自己的球队成功。哇。嗯哼。是的，看你的死敌失败比看到你自己的成功更能让你感觉良好，这就是结论。好吧，天哪，这有点黑暗。哈。
Well, I'm gonna have to think on that. Yeah. I have questions. How do you measure that? Yeah, I didn't- What boxes do you check off? Are they hooked up to a machine? How does this happen?
好吧，我得好好想想这个。是的。我有疑问。你怎么衡量这个？是的，我没——你勾选哪些方框？他们身上连着机器吗？这怎么发生的？
It didn't explain in the article because I was curious about that too, where we, you know, doing like receptors on the brain or whatever, I don't know. This was the experiment and the findings. It's very interesting. Yeah, so think about your own shot in Freuda. Shot in Freuda.
文章里没有解释，因为我也对此很好奇，我们是不是在脑部连接了受体之类的，我不知道。这就是实验和发现。非常有趣。是的，所以想想你自己的幸灾乐祸。幸灾乐祸。
You know, I think the Jim Dwight relationship has a lot of shot and Freuda. I would agree 100%. And a lot of siblings have shot and Freuda. Yes. Yeah, it's true. Speaking of shot and Freuda, there is going to be a pretty epic Jim prank on Dwight coming up. It's true. Dwight and Toby are testing for EMF hot spots.
你知道，我觉得吉姆和德怀特的关系统里有很多幸灾乐祸。我百分之百同意。很多兄弟姐妹之间也有幸灾乐祸。是的。是的，确实如此。说到幸灾乐祸，接下来吉姆要对德怀特进行一次相当史诗级的恶作剧。确实如此。德怀特和托比正在测试电磁场（EMF）热点。
Erin is marking them with big red Xs in tape. And Phyllis walks into work, she's like, what's happening? She's very concerned. I was curious about EMFs. Yeah. They are real electromagnetic fields. They are for the most part believed to be non-harmful, but I guess
艾琳用胶带上的巨大红X把它们标出来。菲利斯走进办公室，她说，发生什么事了？她非常担心。我对电磁场很好奇。是的。它们是真实存在的电磁场。人们普遍认为它们在大多数情况下是无害的，不过我想
in large doses can cause problems. Well you have high frequency EMFs like radiation, maybe some big medical devices that use x-ray imaging machines, but then you have low to mid frequency EMFs and that's probably what's in the Dundermiflin office. It's like microwave ovens, household appliances, cell phones, and they are thought to be harmless to people. But Toby's very concerned. Well, Toby is a worrier, you know?
大剂量可能会导致问题。嗯，你有高频电磁场比如辐射，也许有一些使用X射线成像机器的大型医疗设备，但接着你又有中低频电磁场，这可能就是邓德米夫林办公室里的东西。就像微波炉、家用电器、手机，人们认为它们对人是无害的。但托比非常担心。嗯，托比是个爱担心的人，你知道吗？
He's got his concerns about the radon gas, and now he has concerns about the EMF. Dwight says, listen, everything's up to code. And he has a talking head where he says, you know what? Maybe the wires need insulation, but it's a wire people. I'm not buying it a fur coat. He doesn't want to make any changes to the building. Well, Stanley said, hey, I am not paid to work in a microwave oven. He wants out of there. He walks out. I know. Jim and Pam arrived to work. And Jim is just, man, is he being extra sweet?
他担心氡气，现在他又担心电磁场。德怀特说，听着，一切都符合规范。他有一个访谈镜头，他说，你知道吗？也许电线需要绝缘，但这是电线，各位。我可不打算给它买一件毛皮大衣。他不想对大楼做任何改变。好吧，斯坦利说，嘿，我可不是拿工资来在微波炉里工作的。他想离开那儿。他走了出去。我知道。吉姆和帕姆来上班了。吉姆真是，天哪，他是不是特别贴心？
He's running ahead of her. He's opening the door so she can walk through it. Then he runs ahead to the elevator and he hits the button for her and he has a talking head. He says, you know what? I finally told Pam about this new side job in Philly. She was so cool about it. And now I really wanna do something great for her.
他跑在她前面。他帮她开门让她走过去。然后他跑到电梯前为她按按钮，他有一个访谈镜头。他说，你知道吗？我终于把在费城这个新兼职的事告诉帕姆了。她反应太酷了。现在我真的很想为她做点好事。
Like defend her in a bar fight. In a bar fight? I don't now I really want to do something great for her. Like defend her in a bar fight? I don't know. He wants to do something. He's very motivated by his own guilt of keeping the secret from her for so long and her graciousness in hearing him out. Well, I'm about to stir up a hornet's nest here, but Jim is doing guilt gifting. Oh, mm-hmm. Yeah.
比如在酒吧斗殴中保护她。在酒吧斗殴中？我不知道，我真的很想为她做点好事。比如在酒吧斗殴中保护她？我不知道。他想做点什么。他隐瞒了她这么久，而她听了解释后表现得如此大度，他被自己内心的负罪感深深驱使着。好吧，我在这里要捅马蜂窝了，但吉姆这是在用内疚感送礼。哦，嗯哼。是的。
He knows it was wrong to keep the secret from her. And now this whole episode is Jim trying to find a way to, you know, kind of woo Pam because she forgave him, right? Yeah. It's called guilt gifting. I went down a little bit of an internet rabbit hole about it. It's usually associated with partners who cheat and then buy their wife or husband gifts afterwards. It's a pattern of behavior. Yeah, I think this tracks. Yeah, and Jim, you know, there wasn't a lot of time left for him. The camera crew knew, Darryl knew, he was running out of time to be the one to tell Pam.
他知道瞒着她是不对的。现在这一集全是吉姆在想方设法，你知道的，去讨好帕姆，因为她原谅了他，对吧？是的。这叫“内疚感送礼”。我在互联网上深入了解了一下。这通常与出轨后给妻子或丈夫买礼物的伴侣有关。这是一种行为模式。是的，我觉得这说得通。是的，而且吉姆，你知道的，留给他的时间不多了。摄像组知道，达里尔知道，他快没有时间成为那个向帕姆坦白的人了。
Yeah, I know he's gonna guilt gift her a week off of work, which doesn't work. And then he's going to try to guilt gift her some pie, some pie. Oh, also, this website that talked about guilt gifting, said that ultimately the partner that's getting the guilt gift knows what's happening. And then they can have resentment and feel like their partner is then further trying to manipulate them. Okay, I'm glad you brought this up because I have watched the next episode, which is Here Comes Trouble.
是的，我知道他要送给她一周的假作为内疚感礼物，但这没用。然后他要试着送她一些馅饼作为内疚感礼物，一些馅饼。哦，对了，这个讨论内疚感送礼的网站还说，最终接受内疚感礼物的伴侣是心知肚明的。然后他们会产生怨恨，觉得伴侣是在进一步试图操控他们。好吧，我很高兴你提到这个，因为我已经看了下一集，也就是《麻烦来了》。
Yes, I have too. And there's a little bit of a whiplash because in this episode of Work Bus, Pam is being very easy going about this information. But all of a sudden in the next episode, she brings out a little bit of like sarcastic snark. And I was like, wait a second, last week she seemed cool with it, but now all of a sudden. So I wonder if maybe it's some of this built up
是的，我也看了。并且会产生一点认知失调，因为在《工作巴士》这一集中，帕姆对这个消息表现得很随和。但突然在下一集里，她带出了一点讽刺的尖酸刻薄。我就想，等一下，上周她看起来还挺淡定的，怎么突然就这样了。所以我纳闷，也许这其中包含了一些日积月累的
resentment from the guilt gifting. Yeah. Maybe it does track. You can start to feel manipulated, they said. Yeah. Well, I think what Jim did was manipulative. So there you go. Well, I found it very interesting, you know.
来自内疚感送礼的怨恨。是的。也许确实说得通。他们说，你开始觉得自己被操控了。是的。好吧，我觉得吉姆做的事就是在操控。所以就是这样。好吧，我觉得这很有意思，你知道的。
I find that very interesting. Yeah, it was. Well, next up, Nelly's going to go into Andy's office and he's a total meanie. I was trying to pick my word there. And he's going to give her one minute to talk. He has a little hourglass thing. Yeah, like you'd find in a boggle game or something. There were some earlier drafts of the script where it was made clear that this hourglass is only used for Nelly,
我觉得这非常有趣。是的，确实如此。好吧，接下来，内莉要走进安迪的办公室，而安迪是个十足的讨厌鬼。我刚才在试图挑个词。他要给内莉一分钟时间说话。他有个小沙漏什么的。是的，就像你在图块拼字游戏或其他东西里能找到的那种。早期的一些剧本草稿中明确指出，这个沙漏只针对内莉，
but people thought that was a little bit too mean. And so they decided to let us believe that Andy has a new one minuteminute policy in speaking with him. I was curious why she had the line, not the hourglass again. Yes, because apparently it's just for Nellie. She tells Andy that she wants to adopt a baby and the agency needs a character reference from her employer and she'll write it all, she'll do everything all he has to do is sign it. Andy has a talking head where he's like, sure, you know what?
但人们觉得那样显得有点太刻薄了。于是他们决定让我们相信安迪在和他说话时有一项新的“一分钟政策”。我很奇怪她为什么会有这句台词，“又来沙漏这一套”。是的，因为显然这只针对她。她告诉安迪她想领养一个孩子，机构需要她雇主的性格证明，她会把一切都写好，她会做所有事情，他只需要签字就行。安迪有一个访谈镜头，他说，当然，你知道吗？
I'll read the letter. If she's honest about how evil and unfit of a mother she is, yeah, I'll sign that. So we know this isn't going to go well for Nelly. No. So Jim is going to stir up some trouble here. He's trying to rile up the group and get everybody to get on Dwight's case about these rays. Dwight says that he would have to shut down this office for an entire week in order to fix the problem and Jim's like, ooh, Pam's like that'd be nice. Yeah, so Jim wants to make this happen. He sees his gift. That's right. So he's going to make some popcorn in the kitchen, but he's only going to let one kernel pop. Yeah.
我会读这封信的。如果她坦白自己是多么邪恶、多么不适合当母亲的话，好吧，我会签的。所以我们知道这对他俩来说不会有好结果。不。所以吉姆要在里头挑事了。他想煽动大家，让所有人都去找德怀特的麻烦，针对这些辐射。德怀特说，他必须让这个办公室关闭整整一周才能解决这个问题，而吉姆说，哦，帕姆则说那倒挺好的。是的，所以吉姆想促成此事。他看到了自己的礼物。没错。所以他要在厨房做一些爆米花，但他只让一颗玉米粒爆开。是的。
kitchen, but he's only going to let one kernel pop. Yeah. And then he takes that popcorn bag, he puts it under Dwight's desk right underneath an X. One kernel popped right under Dwight's desk. Yeah. Right under a big red X in the ceiling of the EMF rays, right? Dwight finds the bag and is like, Oh, no. He thinks there's enough electromagnetic fields by his desk to make it only pop once. So this must mean he's sterile. Yeah, he's gonna run into Andy's office and Jim is like, yes, I did it. Week off for you, babe. He's like, let's go on a drive out to the lake
厨房里，但吉姆只让一颗玉米粒爆开。然后他拿着那袋爆米花，把它放在德怀特的办公桌底下，正好在一个X的下方。有一颗玉米粒就在德怀特的办公桌底下爆开了。是的。就在天花板上电磁场辐射的一个巨大红X的正下方！德怀特找到了那袋爆米花，心想，哦，不。他认为他的办公桌附近有足够强的电磁场，能让它只爆开一颗。所以这一定意味着他绝育了。是的，他要冲进安迪的办公室，吉姆心想，耶，我成功了。宝贝，给你放一周假。他说，让我们开车去湖边
with the kids and Pam says, oh, can we stop and get pie? And Jim says, yeah, Laverne's pie's tires fixed also? Of course. I have a little tidbit for you about that. Okay. The legal team at NBC had to clear the name Laverne's Pies, Tires Fixed Also,
和孩子们一起，帕姆说，哦，我们能顺便买个馅饼吗？吉姆说，好啊，拉弗恩馅饼顺便也补个胎？当然。我有一个关于这个的小花絮。好的。NBC的法律团队不得不批准“拉弗恩馅饼，顺便补胎”这个名字，
before we could say it, they had to make sure that there was not a real place. Laverne's Pies, Tires Fixed Also? Yes, and just in case, they also cleared three other options, Laverne's Apple Pies, Laverne's Apple Pies and others, and Laverne's Pies No Cakes Don't Ask. All four cleared. We had our choice, and we went with Laverne's Pies, tires fixed also. That one's my favorite. Totally my favorite.
在我们说出来之前，他们必须确保这不是一个真实的地方。拉弗恩馅饼，顺便补胎？是的，以防万一，他们还批准了其他三个选项，“拉弗恩苹果派”、“拉弗恩苹果派及其他”以及“拉弗恩馅饼不要蛋糕别问”。全部通过。我们有得选，而我们选择了“拉弗恩馅饼，顺便补胎”。那个是我的最爱。绝对是我的最爱。
We should mention that in the kitchen while Jim was making that one kernel pop, in the kitchen while Jim was making that one kernel pop. Darrell is asking Clark to teach him PowerPoint. And Clark's like, dude, just watch the tutorial. And Darrell's like, you are my tutorial. This is gonna set up a whole Darrell Clark storyline that got deleted from the episode. Of Clark teaching Darrell PowerPoint? Yes.
我们应该提一下，当吉姆在厨房里让那颗玉米粒爆开时，当吉姆在厨房里让那颗玉米粒爆开时，达里尔正在请克拉克教他PPT。而克拉克说，老兄，看个教程就行了。达里尔说，你就是我的教程。这将引出一个完整的达里尔和克拉克的故事情节，不过后来被从剧集中删掉了。克拉克教达里尔PPT？是的。
So now Dwight and Andy are gonna emerge from Andy's office. They have a big announcement. They need to leave the office for one whole week, but Dwight has arranged for a temporary workspace, which will be delivered shortly. Cut to everyone outside in the parking lot and a large bus arrives. Here it is, everyone, the work bus.
所以现在德怀特和安迪要从安迪的办公室出来了。他们有个重大宣布。他们需要离开办公室整整一周，但德怀特已经安排了一个临时办公场所，不久就会送到。镜头切到每个人都在室外的停车场里，一辆大巴士开了过来。大家快看，工作巴士。
Mm-hmm. Brent Forrester sent us in an audio clip about the origin of this work bus idea. Let's give it a listen. Where the story came from. We were in the writer's room and we found this story online about a Microsoft office in China that had introduced something called the Enterprise Bus, which was just a bus with work desks in it. So the laborers had to continue working even on their way to work. And it just seemed so demoralizing. And we thought, God, Dw. I love it. The enterprise bus.
嗯。布伦特·福雷斯特给我们发来一段音频剪辑，讲述了“工作巴士”这个创意是怎么来的。我们来听听。这个故事是怎么来的。当时我们在编剧室里，在网上看到了一个故事，讲的是中国的一家微软办公室引入了一种叫做“企业巴士”的东西，其实就是一辆里面装了办公桌的巴士。所以员工们在上班的路上也得继续工作。这让人感觉太打击士气了。我们当时就想，天哪，Dw。我太喜欢了。企业巴士。
Mm-hmm. Wow. I didn't know that. All these years I didn't know that's where this idea came from. Me either. I do have a question. Yeah.
嗯。哇。我以前不知道。这么多年我居然不知道这个创意是这么来的。我也不知道。我倒有个问题。对。
As I watched this bus pull into the parking lot and the Dunder Mifflin crew walks out to see the bus and get on it, I thought, what about the other businesses? Is Vance refrigeration gonnaation going to have to operate on its own work bus? Well, you have something in common with Liz A. from Grantsville, Utah, who said, why didn't Dwight have to provide a work bus for the five families? I thought that immediately. I had a question, which is, why is it Dwight's call whether or not
当我看到这辆巴士开进停车场，邓德米夫林的员工们下车去看巴士并上车时，我在想，那其他公司怎么办呢？范斯冷气公司（Vance Refrigeration）难道也得在一辆属于自己的工作巴士里办公吗？这倒和犹他州格兰茨维尔的莉斯·A（Liz A.）不谋而合了，她说过：“为什么德怀特不给那五个家庭也提供一辆工作巴士呢？”我当时马上就想到了这个。我还有一个问题，就是：
we keep working while he fixes this problem? Wouldn't it be Andy's? Yes, it would. Yeah, Andy's too distracted being mean to Nellie, I guess, to really think about it. Yeah, Andy could just say everyone go remote this week. I know, remote work wasn't really a thing. It wasn't. Not like it is now.
为什么德怀特有权决定在我们解决这个问题时还要不要继续工作？这不该是安迪的决定吗？对，没错。对啊，安迪大概太忙着对内莉刻薄了，都没心思去考虑这事。对啊，安迪完全可以说一句“这周大家都远程办公吧”。我知道，当时远程办公还不怎么流行。确实不流行。不像现在这样。
Like, you could forward your calls, right? I think that technology existed. Could you forward it to your house? I know you could forward calls within your phone system in the office. Like if Pam wanted to go work back by HR, she could forward her calls to a desk back there. But can you forward them to your house?
就像你可以把电话转接一样，对吧？我觉得当时那种技术是存在的。你能把电话转到你家里吗？我知道你可以在办公室的电话系统内部转接电话。比如如果帕姆想去人力资源部后面的位子办公，她可以把电话转接到那边的桌子上。但你能把电话转接到家里吗？
Well, I don't know. There was all those things. Remember how if you hit star 86, you could see who just tried to call you. Like if someone called you and hung up. Oh yeah, on your landline. On your landline, you could hit like star something. I remember that was like a big thing in high school.
嗯，我不知道。当时有各种各样的功能。还记得吗，如果你按星号86，就能看到刚刚是谁试图给你打电话。比如有人给你打电话然后挂断了。哦对，在座机上。在你的座机上，你可以按类似星号什么的。我记得这在高中时可是一件大事。
Hit star, whatever. Speaking of landlines, I had this whole thing with my phone company. I said, I want a landline. And I wanted a true landline because you know, if you call 911 from a landline, they know your exact address. Location, yes.
按星号，随便什么键。说到座机，我之前跟我的电话公司交涉过好久。我说，我想要一部座机。而且我想要一部真正的座机，因为你知道的，如果你用座机拨打911，他们能知道你的精确地址。位置，对。
Like exactly. And you know, my prepper brain, I was like, what if I'm dialing 911 but I can't speak, they'll know my location, right? Yeah. So I was having all this static on my home line whenever I tried to use it, we never use it. It's literally there for my anxious brains, glumen doom oriented future thinking of this time when I'm going to need to call 911 and not speak. That's we pay for this landline. I need it.
就像精准定位一样。而且以我这种老谋深算的危机意识，我想的是，如果我拨打了911却说不出话，他们也能知道我的位置，对吧？对。所以每当我试图使用家里的座机时，总会有很多杂音，其实我们平时根本不用它。它放在那儿纯粹是为了我那焦虑的大脑、为了我那种灾难降临般的末日思维——万一哪天我需要拨打911又说不出话时……这就是我们为什么要装这个座机。我需要它。
That's all I can say. I sleep better at night with it. I also wanted us to have a landline. We had it for years. We never used it. Yeah. And Josh got rid of it. Oh also wanted us to have a landline. We had it for years, we never used it. Yeah. And Josh got rid of it. Oh, well, I couldn't live like that.
我只能说这么多。家里装个座机，我晚上睡觉都踏实些。我也希望我们家能有个座机。我们用了好多年。从来没用过。对。然后乔希把它取消了。哦，我也希望我们家能有个座机。我们用了好多年，从来没用过。对。然后乔希把它取消了。哦，好吧，我可过不了那样日子。
That also surprises me because I think Josh and I are wired similarly, so I am surprised. I don't even know my home number. It's in my cell phone under my home number, so that if I ever need to know it, but it never rings. Yeah. If it does ring, we don't answer it because no one has the number.
这倒也让我挺意外的，因为我觉得我和乔希的思维方式挺像的，所以我很惊讶。我甚至都不记得我家的座机号。它保存在我手机的“家”这个联系人下面，这样如果我哪天需要知道它的号码就能查到，但它从来不响。对。就算它真的响了，我们也不会接，因为根本没人知道这个号。
Anyway, I'm getting off topic. I talked to my phone company because the line was scratchy and it turns out they had put in a digital. It wasn't a true landline. And they tried to tell me they couldn't give me a real landline and I argued with them for days. And finally- You got a true landline. give me a real landline. And I argued with them for days. And finally- You got a true landline.
总之，我扯远了。我联系了电话公司，因为那条线路有杂音，结果他们给装的是数字电话。那根本不是真正的座机。他们还试图告诉我，他们无法提供真正的座机，我和他们争了好几天。最后——你还是搞到了一部真正的座机。给我一部真正的座机。我和他们争了好几天。最后——你搞到了一部真正的座机。
I got a true landline, but it was with much effort. Cause they wanna like bundle you or they wanna like put it with your cable. They wanna make it part of your cable line. I was like, you are not understanding me. I need a true landline for the day that I may, for whatever reason, need to call 911 and not be able to speak, okay?
我搞到了一部真正的座机，但费了好大劲。因为他们总是想把各种业务打包推销给你，或者想把它和你的有线电视绑定。他们想把它弄成你宽带电视线路的一部分。我当时就说：“你们根本没听懂我的意思。我需要一部真正的座机，是为了以防万一哪天我有某种原因需要拨打911却无法说话，好吗？”
What if the zombies are coming, right? Or something, and I cannot make a noise? Yes. I just wanna dial it, and you come. Yes. Yeah. How did I get on this topic? Oh, we were wondering if you can afford.
万一僵尸来了呢，对吧？或者发生别的什么事，而我发不出声音？对。我只想拨个号，然后你们就赶来。对。没错。我怎么扯到这个话题上来了？哦，我们在讨论你能不能买得起……
Wow. Oh, we don't know if you can afford. I told Josh, I don't want a cell phone. I want a landline, like a rotary, like dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig
哇。哦，我们不知道你买不买得起。我跟乔希说，我不要手机。我想要部座机，那种老式的转盘电话，就像嘟加嘟加嘟加嘟加嘟加……
dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig a dig dig a dig with like four devices. Well, it's cause Josh made me get a new phone and I'm so mad about it still. Everything is different on it. I don't like it. I know, I know. Okay, sorry.
嘟加嘟加……带着好几个设备。好吧，那是因为乔希非让我换新手机，我到现在还一肚子火。上面什么都变了。我不喜欢。我知道，我知道。好吧，抱歉。
Where are we? I don't know. I think where we are is that we are about to start working on this bus. Yes. It's very tight quarters and everyone's trying to get work done but they're bumping into each other.
我们说到哪儿了？我不知道。我想我们说到我们要开始在这辆巴士里干活了。对。空间非常狭窄，每个人都想把工作干完，但总是挤来挤去。
There is the best scene. It is my favorite scene from this whole entire episode. It made me laugh so hard. It's in deleted scenes on the DVD. I can't play it for you because it's visual, it's a sight gag, but while the work bus is parked in the parking lot and everyone's trying to get work done, Phyllis comes on the bus with a takeout food container that clearly is the worst smelling food. I never heard of this. Everyone's reactions to this stinky food is so hilarious. John is so funny.
这里有一个最棒的场景。这是整集中我最喜欢的场景。把我笑得前仰后合。它在DVD的删减片段里。我没法放给你们看，因为它是视觉上的，是个视觉笑话，当工作巴士停在停车场，每个人都在努力工作时，菲莉丝拿着一个外卖餐盒上了车，那盒里的食物气味简直臭不可闻。我以前从没听说过这个。每个人对这股臭味的反应都太搞笑了。约翰太搞笑了。
He ultimately takes the container away from Phyllis and shoves it into the microwave and shuts the door. Everyone is like, I'm gonna put it in stories because it's really funny. Well, something I remember from these scenes shooting in the parking lot were how funny John Krasinski and Brian Cranston were because we should note Brian is a very funny guy. Yeah, he's very quick-witted. The two of them were doing bits,
他最后从菲莉丝手里抢过餐盒，塞进微波炉里并关上了门。大家都觉得——我要把它发到快拍里，因为真的太搞笑了。对了，我记得当时在停车场拍这些场景时，约翰·卡拉辛斯基和布赖恩·克兰斯顿简直太搞笑了，我们得说，布赖恩是个非常搞笑的人。对，他脑子转得极快。他们俩一直在即兴表演，
and it was really lightening the mood because it was very hot on this bus. When we're on that bus and we're all cramped and we're like pretending like we're being hot and like annoyed, we were pretty much hot and annoyed because there was no air conditioner. They removed the air conditioner. We were just in a hot tin can.
这真的缓和了气氛，因为这辆巴士里实在是太热了。当我们在那辆车里挤成一团，假装很热很烦躁时，其实我们差不多就是又热又烦躁，因为根本没有空调。他们把空调拆了。我们就待在一个炽热的铁罐头里。
Yes. To give you an idea of what all they put inside this bus to make it a quote work bus, I want to paint a picture for you guys of how many things were inside this little tiny basically airport shuttle bus. We had desks, rolling chairs, lamps, a water cooler with real water in it, a printer, computers, papers, pencils, pins, notepads, tape dispensers, staplers, little mini fans, a microwave, a giant screen TV, a coffee maker, coffee pot, coffee mugs, 14 actors and four crew members. Yes.
是的。为了让大家对他们为了把这辆车变成所谓的“工作巴士”而在里面塞了多少东西有个概念，我想给大家勾勒一下，在这辆基本上只有机场穿梭巴士那么大的小车里，到底塞了多少东西。我们有办公桌、带轮子的椅子、台灯、带真水的饮水机、打印机、电脑、纸张、铅笔、大头针、记事本、胶带座、订书机、迷你小风扇、微波炉、巨型电视屏幕、咖啡机、咖啡壶、咖啡马克杯，14位演员和4名剧组工作人员。是的。
Yeah, that's what was all in the bus. And I have to share one other thing. When I was going through documenting everything that was in the bus and I looked at the chairs, I got a lump in my throat because I still have one of the work bus chairs that you see us sitting in. It's the chair that I sit in whenever we podcast from home in our closet. And the reason I have it is I was moving and I did not have a chair for my desk at home. And Phil Shea was like, Andj, at the end of work bus, I'll just snag one of these chairs for you. He always was looking out for us and I still have that
对，车里装的就是这些东西。我必须分享另一件事。当我过目并记录车里的所有东西、看到那些椅子时，我差点哽咽，因为我们录播客时坐在上面、放在家里衣帽间的那把椅子，我至今还留着一辆工作巴士上的椅子。我留着它的原因是我当时在搬家，家里办公桌正好没有椅子。菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）就说：“安吉，等工作巴士拍完，我帮你顺一把椅子走。”他总是那么照顾我们，我到现在还留着那把
chair. Yeah, you guys know Phil passed last year. And that story is making me emotional. I know. Because I had to share it though. But you, oh, of course. And that's the thing about Phil was that like, you'd just be having conversation with him, you're just telling him, I'm moving and this and that
椅子呢。对，你们知道菲尔去年去世了。那个故事让我听了很感触。我知道。因为我还是想把它分享出来。但是你，哦，当然了。这就是菲尔的为人，你会跟他随口聊天，只是告诉他你正在搬家，还有这啊那啊的，
and you're talking and then he's filing that away and he's thinking. Do you need a chair? What do you need? Yeah, I'll get you a chair. You can take one of these. That's exactly what he did. And then I, at the end of the day,
然后你一边聊，他就一边把这些记在心里，开始琢磨了。你需要椅子吗？你需要什么？行，我给你弄把椅子。你可以拿走一把。他就是这样的人。然后到了那天结束的时候，
I was walking to my car and he was like, Anne, chair, I got you a chair. So cool. I did wanna point out something that you mentioned here in your list, Angela, and that you know about your chair, which is that they are rolly. Yes, they roll. So just something I want us to note.
我正走向自己的汽车，他就对我说：“安吉，椅子，我给你弄了一把椅子。”太酷了。我其实想指出你在清单里提到的一点，安吉，而且你也知道你那把椅子的特点，那就是它们带轮子。对，它们会滚动。所以这是我想让大家注意的一点。
As we're moving in a moving vehicle. Right. Yes. I did have a thought as well. I don't know if anyone else watching had this thought. Much in the way my brain goes to the conference room of like, who's setting this up? Who's moving all this out there? Who set up this work bus? How long did it take? I think the idea is that Dwight rented it as fully loaded. Yeah. Oh, that this is an item that you can get that rolls in like that. That's kind of a pun. Yes. It is a pun. It's not kind of a pun. It is a pun. All right. Well, next up, Erin notices that Nelly has an adoption application form. And Nelly says, maybe you can give me some help because you were once adopted. But Erin says, oh no, I never ended up getting adopted.
当我们坐在一辆行驶中的交通工具里时。没错。是的。我也产生了一个想法。不知道看节目的其他人有没有这种想法。就像我看着会议室时脑子里总会想：这一切是谁布置的？谁把这些东西搬到外面的？这辆工作巴士是谁布置的？花了多长时间？我想剧里的设定是德怀特租来的时候就是一应俱全的。对。哦，这是一种可以整车开过来的那种租赁物品。这算是个双关语吧。对，这就是个双关语。不只算有点双关，它就是个双关。好吧，接下来，埃琳发现内莉有一份收养申请表。内莉说，也许你能帮帮我，因为你曾经被收养过。但埃琳说：“哦不，我最后并没有被收养。”
I got close a few times, but it didn't happen. I don't know why, maybe just because I'm unlovable. My gosh. Like you're hard. I know. But she agrees to help Nelly on the application just with her general knowledge. But she says, please don't tell Andy I'm helping you. And Nelly knows instantly why because I guess he refers to her as the Loch Ness Monster.
我有几次差一点成功了，但还是没成。我不知道为什么，也许就因为我这人不可爱吧。天哪。听着真让人揪心。我知道。但她还是答应仅凭自己的常识在申请表上帮内莉一把。不过她说：“请别告诉安迪我在帮你。”内莉一听就知道为什么了，因为我猜安迪总是管她叫“尼斯湖水怪”。
Yeah. So everyone is already starting to get grumpy being in such tight quarters with one another. Angela's gonna go and in the overhead compartment is a printer. I don't know if you knew what she was doing. It said that there was a printer in there that she's supposed to reach for.
对。所以大家挤在这么狭窄的空间里，已经开始变得暴躁了。安吉拉走过去，头顶的行李架上放着一台打印机。我不知道你当时知不知道她在干什么。剧本说那里有一台打印机，她应该伸手去拿。
And all these papers come down. It spills a drink into Pam's lap. In the meantime, Clark has been pacing because he, I guess, has to stretch his legs and Stanley gets really pissed off about that. Things are coming to a head. Yeah. When the paper falls down, it falls on Pam, knocks her coffee onto her lap. She has to get off the bus. Jim is freaking out, because the whole point here was that he was gonna make Pam's week better, and now Pam is covered in coffee,
结果一堆文件掉了下来。还把一杯饮料洒在了帕姆的腿上。与此同时，克拉克一直在走来走去，因为我猜他得活动活动腿脚，斯坦利为此感到非常火大。矛盾正在激化。对。当文件掉下来时，正好砸在帕姆身上，把她的咖啡泼到了腿上。她不得不下车。吉姆快急疯了，因为他本来的全部意图是想让帕姆这周过得好一点，结果现在帕姆身上沾满了咖啡，
and she is working on this tiny bus. So her week has gotten worse, and his, what is it called, guilt gifting? It's not working out. It's not working out. So he decides to convince Andy that they should fire up this bus and go get some pie. Andy agrees.
而且她还得在这辆极小的巴士里工作。所以她这周反而更糟糕了，而他的那种行为——叫什么来着？内疚式送礼？根本不管用。根本行不通。于是他决定说服安迪把这辆巴士开起来，去买点派。安迪同意了。
Yeah. Next stop, Laverne's pie's tires fixed also. Pam was getting on the bus when she hears this. She's happy. All right, pie. So the bus pulls out of the driveway, but it reveals that Clark and Darrell have been left behind.
对。下一站，顺便把拉弗恩派店（Laverne's Pie）的轮胎也修了。帕姆正要上车时听到了这个消息。她很高兴。太好了，有派吃。于是巴士开出了车道，却发现克拉克和达瑞尔被落在后面了。
We had a fan question from Laura A. in South Jordan, Utah, who said, did Darrell and Clark get left behind for some reason? Okay. So earlier in this episode, when we had Darrell and Clark in the kitchen and Darrell's asking Clark to teach him PowerPoint, that was actually a whole extended storyline. So Laura, you are right, something did happen. A lot of this plays out in the deleted scenes on the DVD, but there were also some nuggets in the script.
我们收到了来自犹他州南约旦的劳拉·A（Laura A.）的粉丝提问，她说：“达瑞尔和克拉克是不是因为什么原因被落在后面了？”好吧。所以在这集的前面部分，当我们在厨房看到达瑞尔和克拉克，并且达瑞尔让克拉克教他PPT时，那其实是一条很长的延伸剧情线。所以劳拉，你猜对了，确实发生了一些事。大部分内容都在DVD的删减片段里展现了，不过剧本里也有一些精彩小片段。
I'm gonna share both. There was a scene where Daryl walks up to Jim and says, "'Hey, I'm learning PowerPoint for my new career.'" You know, kind of like wink, wink. Here's how it starts, let's hear it. Hey, if you don't wanna teach me PowerPoint, just new career. You know, kinda like wink wink. Here's how it starts, let's hear it. Hey, if you don't wanna teach me PowerPoint, just say so. I don't wanna teach you PowerPoint. Come on, just show me the PowerPoint.
我两部分都会分享。有一个场景是达瑞尔走到吉姆面前说：“嘿，我在为我的新职业学习PPT。”你知道的，有点像眨眼暗示那种感觉。它是这样开始的，我们来听听。嘿，如果你不想教我PPT，就直说新职业。你知道，有点像眨眼暗示。它是这样开始的，我们来听听。嘿，如果你不想教我PPT，就直说。我才不想教你PPT呢。拜托，就教我PPT嘛。
Just do the tutorial. You're the tutorial. No dude, I'm not, I'm not the tutorial. You could be. Mm-mm. Okay, listen, I know Quicken, After Effects, Photoshop, and AutoCAD, which is like the equivalent of owning a pickup truck. Hey, you free this weekend? Yeah, man, let's hang out. Oh, I haven't-in, after effects, photoshop, and auto-cat, which is like the equivalent of owning a pickup truck.
就教我那个教程。你就是教程。不，老兄，我不是，我才不是教程呢。你可以是。嗯-嗯。好吧，听着，我会Quicken、After Effects、Photoshop和AutoCAD，这相当于拥有一辆皮卡。嘿，这周末你有空吗？行啊，老兄，我们一起出去玩吧。哦，我还没……After Effects、Photoshop和AutoCAD，这相当于拥有一辆皮卡。
Hey, you free this weekend? Yeah, man, let's hang out. Oh, how about instead of hanging out, you design my website? Well, let me just delete you out of my phone real quick because you suck. That's what I'm dealing with with Darryl right now. So that would have set up their whole runner? Yes.
嘿，这周末你有空吗？行啊，老兄，我们一起出去玩吧。哦，与其出去玩，不如你帮我设计个网站怎么样？好吧，那我赶紧把你从我手机通讯录里删了，因为你太讨厌了。这就是我现在跟达瑞尔打交道的情况。所以这就铺垫了他们俩的整条支线剧情？对。
And then when the bus pulls away, this is how the scene read in the shooting draft. Okay. The camera whips to caffeine corner where Daryl and Clark are sipping cocoa and reading magazines. Daryl without looking up says stop. Clark says come back. Daryl says too late.
然后当巴士开走时，拍摄初稿中的场景是这样的。镜头猛地转向咖啡角，达瑞尔和克拉克正在啜饮热可可并翻阅杂志。达瑞尔头也没抬地说：“停。”克拉克说：“回来。”达瑞尔说：“太迟了。”
And then Daryl turns to Clark and says so ready to teach me PowerPoint? Clark says nope. Daryl goes I'll take that as a yes. And Clark goes can't we just play video games? And Darrell goes, we can play PowerPoint. Then Clark is going to have a talking head where he's getting really frustrated that Darrell is just driving him crazy, wanting to learn PowerPoint. And then there's another scene where Darrell is trying to copy and paste an image.
然后达瑞尔转向克拉克说：“准备好教我PPT了吗？”克拉克说：“没门。”达瑞尔说：“我就当你答应了。”克拉克说：“难道我们不能打电子游戏吗？”达瑞尔说：“我们可以做PPT。”然后克拉克会有一个单采镜头，表现出他被达瑞尔非要学PPT的行为搞得快要抓狂了。接着还有另一个场景，达瑞尔试图复制和粘贴一张图片。
And anyway, he just drives Clark absolutely bananas. But it was a whole runner. That's what was happening back at Dunder Mifflin. I can't believe they didn't just go home. No kidding! Well, I think we should take a break because when we come back, all of the mishaps will be occurring. And we have a lot to say about those. Oh, we do. We are back and it's time for a roll call.
总之，他把克拉克气得快要发疯了。但这整条是一条支线剧情。这就是邓德米夫林办公室里发生的事情。我简直不敢相信他们居然没直接回家。可不是嘛！好吧，我想我们该休息一下了，因为等我们回来时，各种倒霉事就要发生了。我们对此有很多话要说。哦，确实有。我们回来了，现在是点名时间。
Yes! We are traveling down the road. We're happy. We're all singing this song. Everyone's going to get pie. This is a happy time. Writer Brent Forrester said that this was inspired by the scene in Spike Lee's movie Get on the Bus when they do a Shabuya roll call. We got a lot of fan mail about this. Taryn E. from Chicago, Illinois said were there any alts to the Shabuya roll call song?
耶！我们在路上行驶着。我们很开心。我们都在唱这首歌。每个人都要去吃派。这是一个快乐的时刻。编剧布朗·福雷斯特说，这灵感来源于斯派克·李的电影《巴士底》（Get on the Bus）中他们玩“涩谷点名”（Shabuya roll call）的那场戏。我们收到了很多关于这部分的粉丝来信。来自伊利诺伊州芝加哥的泰伦·E（Taryn E.）说：“涩谷点名之歌还有没有别的替代歌词？”
And Laura A. from South Jordan, Utah said were there more roll calls to the Shibuya Roll Call song and Laura A. from South Jordan, Utah said were there more roll calls that didn't make it in? Oh, Taryn and Laura, do I have stuff for you guys? There were so many extra Shibuya Roll Calls. Okay, there's a ton in the Candy Bag alts. I also want to play you an extended part of Shibuya Roll Call that's in the deleted scenes on the DVDs. Let's start there, then we're going to dive into the candy bag. I am so glad you're sharing this, Angela, because we shot this for so long,
来自犹他州南约旦的劳拉·A（Laura A.）说：“涩谷点名之歌还有没有别的点名段落没能剪进正片里？”哦，泰伦和劳拉，我给你们准备了好东西！有超多额外的涩谷点名歌词。好吧，糖果袋（Candy Bag）里有海量的备选歌词。我还想播放一段收录在DVD删减片段里的、加长版的涩谷点名。我们从那儿开始，然后就深入探讨糖果袋里的存货。我太高兴你分享这个了，安吉拉，因为我们拍了超级久，
this was stuck in my head for weeks. Oh, yeah. I mean, we spent hours on this and so little made it into the episode. I cannot wait to hear this. Shabuya, ya, ya, Shabuya, Roll call. My name is Oscar. Yeah. Why am I here? Yeah.
这首歌在我脑子里盘旋了好几个星期。哦，对啊。我是说，我们在上面花了好几个小时，结果剪进正片里的却那么少。我迫不及待想听听这个了。涩谷，呀，呀，涩谷，点名。我的名字叫奥斯卡。Yeah。为什么我会在这儿？Yeah。
I've clearly chosen. Yeah. The Roll career. Roll call. Shabuya, ya, ya, Shabuya, Roll call. It's my year turn. I'm not doing it. Yeah.
我显然做出了选择。Yeah。滚动的职业。点名。涩谷，呀，呀，涩谷，点名。轮到我了。我不干。Yeah。
You're wasting your time. Yeah. No, this doesn't count. Yeah. I will not rhyme. Damn it. Roll call. First of all, just listening to all of that just made me smile. Count. Yeah. I will not rhyme. Dammit. Robocop. First of all, just listening to all of that just made me smile.
你在浪费时间。Yeah。不，这不算。Yeah。我才不押韵呢。该死。点名。首先，光是听着这些就让我忍不住微笑。算数。Yeah。我才不押韵呢。该死。机器人警察。首先，光是听着这些就让我忍不住微笑。
Phyllis really did lose it laughing. She did. That's her real laugh. It is. And that was just such a fun day. And we were all really having fun. Angela, it must have been hard for you because your character was not supposed to want to do this.
菲莉丝真的是笑得前仰后合。她确实是。那是她真正的笑声。没错。那真的是非常有趣的一天。我们当时也真的是在玩得很开心。安吉拉，对你来说一定很难熬吧，因为你的角色按设定是不想参与进来的。
No. And you must have felt the energy from the rest of us. I mean, this was probably the happiest we were on this shoot. I know. With the bus moving. And I was not allowed to participate. I know. I had to sit there and roll my eyes.
对啊。而且你肯定能感受到我们其他人的能量。我是说，这可能是我们在这次拍摄中最快乐的时候了。我知道。当时车还在开着。而我却不被允许参与。我知道。我只能坐在那里狂翻白眼。
So there were a few characters in the shooting draft that didn't want to participate. They just want to work. When they're at work, they want to work. Yes. Stanley, Angela, and Dwight. Yes. There is a deleted Angela talking head
所以拍摄初稿里有几个角色是不想参与的。他们只想工作。当他们在工作时，他们就只想工作。对。斯坦利、安吉拉和德怀特。没错。有一个被删掉的安吉拉单采镜头，
where she's just like, listen, this is nonsense. And then Stanley actually in the shooting draft has a Shabuya Roe call. He does? Yes, and a few other characters do too. And there's fun alts. I want to read them to you. Okay, before I start reading all of these
她在里面就说：“听着，这简直是无稽之谈。”然后斯坦利在拍摄初稿里其实也有一个涩谷点名。他有吗？对，还有其他几个角色也有。而且还有很多有趣的备选歌词。我想读给你们听。好吧，在我开始朗读所有这些
candy bag alts for Shabuya Roe Call, Cassie, Sam, Jenna, I'm gonna need your help. Oh, dear. Please don't make me do this again. You have to do the yeah. Oh, gosh. You don't have to do Shibuya Roe Call. I just need you to go yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay. All right, guys. I fear this is already gonna be in my head for days.
关于涩谷点名的糖果袋备选歌词之前，卡西、萨姆、珍娜，我需要你们的帮忙。哦，天哪。求求你们别让我再干这个了。你们得负责喊那个“Yeah”。哦，天哪。你们不用唱涩谷点名。我只需要你们喊“Yeah”。好吧。好吧。好吧。好吧，伙计们。我怕这又要在我脑子里盘旋好几天了。
Sam, Cassie, so we're gonna start with Stanley. Okay. Stanley is doing his crossword, and this is what he says. You can call me Stanley. Yeah. It wouldn't hurt. Yeah.
萨姆、卡西，那我们从斯坦利开始。好吧。斯坦利正在做他的填字游戏，他是这么说的。你可以叫我斯坦利。Yeah。这又没什么损失。Yeah。
But what I really need. Yeah. Is a three letter word for shirt. Roll call. Okay. Here's the Jim Candy Bag Alt. You can call me Jim. Yeah.
但我真正需要的是。Yeah。一个三个字母的“衬衫”英文单词。点名。好吧。接下来是吉姆的糖果袋备选歌词。你可以叫我吉姆。Yeah。
Or Dr. Fly. Yeah. Step on the court. Yeah. I'll show you why. Roll call. Okay, so Andy had a few. For the first one, Andy is sitting next to Erin and it went like this. My name is Andy. Yeah. Her hair is red. Yeah. I'll be her Mandy. Yeah. Until I'm dead. Roll call. Here's the second one for Andy. My name is Andy. Yeah. I'm regional manager. Yeah. My favorite bird type. Yeah. Is the Scarlet Tannager. Roll call. Okay, here we go for Nelly. My name is Nelly. Yeah. I drank quite a large mountain dew. Yeah. Now I'm on a
或者“飞人”博士。Yeah。踏上球场。Yeah。我会让你看看为什么。点名。好吧，安迪有几段。第一段是安迪坐在埃琳旁边，它是这样的。我的名字叫安迪。Yeah。她的头发是红色的。Yeah。我会做她的曼迪。Yeah。直到我死去。点名。这是安迪的第二段。我的名字叫安迪。Yeah。我是区域经理。Yeah。我最喜欢的鸟类。Yeah。是猩红唐纳雀。点名。好吧，接下来轮到内莉。我的名字叫内莉。Yeah。我喝了一大罐激浪。Yeah。现在我在一辆……
bus. Yeah. And there's no Lou. Roll call. Roll call. Another one for Nelly. My name is Nelly. Yeah. You can buy me a drink. Yeah. I'm a single lady.
巴士上。Yeah。而且车里没有厕所。点名。点名。内莉的另一段。我的名字叫内莉。Yeah。你可以请我喝一杯。Yeah。我是个单身女郎。
Yeah. Wink, wink and a clink. Roll call. Roll call. And then Oscar, by the way Brent Forester shared with us, the one that Oscar does in the actual episode was his favorite of all of them. Yes.
Yeah。眨个眼，碰个杯。点名。点名。然后奥斯卡——顺便说一句，布兰特·福雷斯特告诉我们，奥斯卡在正片里用的那段是他所有人里面最喜欢的。对。
But here was Oscar's candy bag alt. It really made me laugh. My name is Oscar. Yeah. I like to read. Yeah. Mostly nonfiction. Yeah.
但这是奥斯卡的糖果袋备选歌词。真的把我笑惨了。我的名字叫奥斯卡。Yeah。我喜欢阅读。Yeah。主要是纪实作品。Yeah。
Because when I read modern fiction, I always wind up disappointed. There's too much focus on innovating the form at the expense of a good story, well told. And frankly frankly good stories are what readers want and the publishing industry needs. Roll call! All right, Taryn and Laura, there you go. All the candy bag alts and the extras on the DVDs. Well, I loved that, Angela. And like I said, we had so much fun shooting this. In fact, we were laughing so much, this is the scene where Ellie wet her pants.
因为当我阅读现代小说时，我总是以失望告终。它们把太多的精力放在了形式创新上，却牺牲了一个好故事、一个讲得好的故事。坦白说，坦白说，好故事才是读者想要的，也是出版行业所需要的。点名！好了，泰伦和劳拉，这就是全部了。所有的糖果袋备选歌词和DVD上的额外花絮。嗯，我太喜欢这个了，安吉拉。就像我说的，我们拍的时候太开心了。事实上，我们笑得太厉害了，这就是埃莉尿裤子的那一幕。
Yes! This was the third scene we shot this day. We'd been shooting on the bus for two days now. This was our last day on the bus. We were all a little bit goofy. You know what? I'm gonna let Ellie tell you the story. Here it is.
对！这是我们这天拍的第三场戏。我们当时已经在车上拍了两天了。这是我们在车上的最后一天。我们都显得有点傻乎乎的。你知道吗？我让埃莉来给你们讲这个故事。录音在这儿。
Hello, Jenna. Hello, Angela. Hello, office ladies, listeners, everywhere. This is Ellie Kemper. I am here to share with you the chilling tale of when I, a grown woman in her 30s, wet my pants. That is, I went pee-pee in my pants during the filming of the office episode called Work Bus, which you ladies might recall, we had nicknamed death bus because a lot of things kept going
哈喽，珍娜。哈喽，安吉拉。哈喽，办公室女士播客的听众们，你们好。我是埃莉·肯珀（Ellie Kemper）。我在这里要跟你们分享一个令人毛骨悚然的故事：当我还一个三十多岁的成年女性时，我尿裤子了。也就是说，在拍摄那集名叫《工作巴士》的《办公室》剧集期间，我尿在裤子里了。大家可能还记得，我们当时给它起了个外号叫“死亡巴士”，因为那集拍摄期间出了好多
wrong during that episode. Things out of anybody's control. It was just one of those weeks where life happens and things kept going wrong. One of those things was my incontinence. Here's what happened. John Krasinski was leading a song called Shabuya Roll Call. And something that John was doing, and I can't recall what it was, it was making me laugh so very hard off camera. And I think it was just a face he was making. And I don't know, I had, there
状况。都是超出任何人控制的事情。那就是那种生活总爱跟人开玩笑、各种状况百出的倒霉星期之一。其中一个状况就是我的尿失禁。事情是这样的。约翰·卡拉辛斯基当时在带头唱一首叫《涩谷点名》的歌。约翰当时在做的某个动作——我记不清具体是什么了，把镜头外的我逗得哈哈大笑。我想那可能只是他当时做的某个鬼脸。我也不知道，当时……
was no bathroom on the work slash death bus. There's no restroom and This is not the first time this has happened to me It's like the most wonderful thing and the most excruciating thing because I'm laughing so hard at something So therefore I'm filled with such joy and it's such a nice moment immediately followed by sheer horror as I realize I've laughed so hard that I've lost control of my body and I've gone peepee in my, well actually in my skirt. And that's happened to me a number of times in my life and that was one of them, that was one of the occasions and I had sat, I was sitting down on the bus seat when that happened and as it as I realized what had just happened, I thought, well, I won't be able to get up
工作/死亡巴士上没有洗没有手间。车上没有洗手间，而且这也不是我第一次遇到这种事了。这感觉就像是最美妙的事，也是最折磨的事，因为我对某件事笑得前仰后合。所以因此我充满了喜悦，那是一个非常美好的时刻，紧接着就是纯粹的惊恐，因为我意识到我笑得太厉害，以至于失去了对身体的控制，我尿尿在我的——其实是尿在了裙子里。我在生活中经历过好几次这种情况，那次就是其中之一，那是其中一个场合。当时事情发生时，我正坐在巴士的座位上，当我意识到刚刚发生了什么时，我想：好吧，我不能站起来，
until wrap. I will just sit here in my mess until we wrap for the day. But of course, that wasn't realistic. They had to change the lights. They had to do things with the bus. And I got up and yeah, and Brian Baumgartner was the first person to say, Ellie did you wet your pants? And I said yeah I did, Brian. And I just want to say none, not one of the ladies on the bus was in any way phased. Oh you what okay well does anybody have an extra
直到收工。我就得坐在我这一滩狼藉里，直到今天的工作结束。但当然，那是不现实的。他们得换灯光。他们得对巴士做一些调整。于是我站了起来，然后——布赖恩·巴姆加特纳是第一个开口问的人：“埃莉，你尿裤子了吗？”我说：“对啊，我尿了，布赖恩。”我只想说，车上的女士们没有一个人感到有任何尴尬。哦，你——好吧，那有人有备用的
pair? Does it do we have a wardrobe change? Everybody took it. All the ladies took it in stride and the men were grossed out. Okay. I don't know if every single one was. I just remember the men unsure at all what to do with this and all of the women thought, well, that's just another day of being a woman. So that is the story of me wetting my pants on the office work bus. Thank you for letting me share this cautionary tale. And I hope all of you will be able to sleep tonight knowing this, this haunted, haunted story that happened in real life. Okay, bye. My goodness, Ellie, I'll just never forget it.
裤子吗？我们有换洗的戏服吗？每个人都接受了。所有的女士都泰然处之，而男士们则觉得恶心。好吧。我不知道是不是每个人都这样。我只记得男人们完全不知所措，不知道该怎么面对这件事，而所有的女人们都觉得，好吧，这就是当女人的又常有的一天。这就是我在《办公室》工作巴士上尿裤子的故事。谢谢你们让我分享这个警示故事。希望今晚大家听了这个闹鬼般的、真实发生的故事后还能睡得着觉。好了，拜拜。天哪，埃莉，我永远都不会忘记这一幕。
She was still laughing so hard. Yes. Then at the fact that she had peed. She had peed. Yes. I'll never forget when she got up, the wardrobe van came up to help her get a change. When she got up, the wardrobe van came up to help her get a change. When she got up, we had grabbed paper towels and put it on the peace spot on her chair.
她当时还在哈哈大笑。对。为了她自己尿了这件事。她尿了。对。我永远不会忘记她站起来时，服装车开过来帮她换衣服。她站起来的时候，服装车开过来帮她换衣服。她站起来时，我们抓了纸巾放在她椅子上的尿湿处。
Yeah, there wasn't much. There were some little napkins and then like papers. We just put it on top. Yeah, dab it. Oh my goodness. Oh my gosh. Well, I remember this too because I remember we were like, oh my gosh, we're always going to remember this episode because it's the episode where Ellie peed her pants.
对，没剩多少了。有一些小餐巾纸，然后还有一些文件。我们就直接盖在上面了。对，吸一下。天哪。天哪。好吧，我也记得这件事，因为我记得当时我们在想：“天哪，我们永远都会记住这集，因为这是埃莉尿裤子的那一集。”
Yeah. We thought this was going to be the memorable thing about this episode. Heed her pants work bus, not death bus. We could not have imagined what was to come. Thank you, Ellie, so much for sending in your story. I know, Ellie. That was fantastic. I also want to point out if you watch us during this song, just how very sweaty both John and Brian are in this scene. Just note it, we were so hot. So hot. And the guys had on their blazers and oh, this was the first time we were
对。我们当时以为这会是这集最让人记忆深刻的事呢。尿裤子的工作巴士，而不是死亡巴士。我们当时绝不会想到后面还会发生什么。谢谢你，埃莉，非常感谢你发来你的故事。我知道，埃莉。太精彩了。我还想指出一点，如果你在这首歌期间看我们的镜头，就会发现约翰和布赖恩在这场戏里出汗出的有多厉害。注意一下，我们当时真的太热了。太热了。而且男士们还穿着西装外套，哦，这是我们第一次……
comfortable. I don't recall being hot. I do remember feeling kind of like stagnant. It was stuffy. Yeah. Like no air moving. Yeah. Yeah. We've got a little one-off joke coming up. Dwight notices a hitchhiker on the side of the road and he goes to pick this person up and guess what? It's Creed. Yeah. Creed's like, turns out he's playing hooky for work. I thought Creed did such a fantastic job,
舒服。我不记得当时觉得热。我只记得感觉有点闷热。空气很不流通。对。就好像没有空气在流动。对。对。我们接下来要迎来一个简短的小笑话。德怀特注意到路边有个搭便车的人，他过去把这个人接上了车，你猜怎么着？是克里德。对。克里德——原来他是逃班出来的。我觉得克里德演得太棒了，
his expression when he sees everyone on the bus was so good. We're gonna have a moment now where the bus is clearly pulled over. Everyone is posing for a group photo in front of a big rooster. Location alert, we filmed these rooster scenes at Woodley Park. This was actually the same day that we shot all the baseball field stuff.
他看到车上所有人的那个表情简直绝了。接下来我们会有一个场景，巴士明显停在路边。大家都在一个巨大的公鸡雕塑前摆姿势拍集体照。外景地警报，我们是在伍德利公园（Woodley Park）拍摄这些大公鸡场景的。这其实就是我们拍所有棒球场戏份的同一天。
This happened on our first day on location it was really lovely yeah we had a beautiful base camp with our trailers and changes of clothes and. Great lunch this was a wonderful day i brought my football park was right there so we could toss the ball. This was a wonderful day. But Pam is gonna notice that Dwight has kind of wandered off on his own, and she's kind of planting the seed. Like, what's going on with Dwight? You know, Pam is always pretty attuned to Dwight's, I guess, emotional life.
这是我们第一天去外景地，天气真的很可爱，对，我们的房车和换衣间有个非常棒的大本营。午餐也很棒，这真是美好的一天，我把我的橄榄球带上了，公园就在旁边，所以我们可以传球。这真是美好的一天。但帕姆会注意到德怀特有点独自一人四处闲逛，她其实是在暗中埋下伏笔。比如，德怀特这是怎么了？你知道的，帕姆对德怀特的精神世界一直挺敏感的。
She really is. She has a soft spot for him. Well, now I think it's time for us to have a get to know your cast and crew moment from the call sheet. Oh, all right. This is about John Eagot who worked in Special Effects. Three things you didn't know about John. He has too many favorite books and cannot pick just one.
她真的很懂他。对他的软肋很了解。好吧，现在我想是时候从通告单上挑出一个“了解你的剧组和演员”的环节了。哦，太好了。这是关于在特效部门工作的约翰·埃戈特（John Eagot）的。关于约翰你不知道的三件事。他喜爱的书太多了，无法只挑出一本。
If it is written, he will read it. The prettiest place he has ever been is Lake Tahoe in the 1960s. He was once a DJ in a French bordello, and his favorite midnight snack is cold Colonel Sanders. I think they're adding a new question. What's your favorite midnight snack? I'll be adding that the next time we have a guest. You all know mine. Oh, cereal. Lucky charms. Lucky charms, yeah. I think that's a great question to ask people. You know, Angela, since we've gone off topic here
只要是写出来的东西，他都会读。他去过最漂亮的地方是20世纪60年代的太浩湖。他曾经是一家法国妓院的DJ，他最喜欢的午夜小吃是冷盘肯德基上校炸鸡。我想他们这是在加一个新问题。你最喜欢的午夜小吃是什么？下次我们有嘉宾时我也会加上这个。你们都知道我的。哦，麦片。幸运麦片（Lucky charms）。幸运麦片，对。我觉得这是个问大家的好问题。你知道吗，安吉拉，既然我们刚才稍微扯远了一点，
for just a moment, over the break, I started realizing that I'm probably gonna get a bunch of like mail from people about my landline 911 paranoia, about knowing my location. I feel like people are gonna tell me that actually my cell phone can pinpoint my location. And I just want everyone to know that I don't turn on my locations on my cell phone.
在休息期间，我开始意识到我可能马上要收到一堆人发来的邮件，都是关于我那种对座机拨打911、以及准确定位我位置的偏执狂热的。我觉得大家会告诉我，其实我的手机就能精确定位我的位置。我只想让每个人都知道，我从来不打开手机上的定位功能。
And the reason that I don't do that is very important to me. And it is because I don't wanna get framed for a crime. You don't wanna get pinged in the cell phone. Yeah, I don't like the idea that like I might get framed one day for a major crime because the location thing was on on my cell phone. And so you guys, I just need you all to know that I really need that landline
我不这么做的原因对我来说非常重要。原因就是我不想被诬陷犯罪。你可不想被手机定位追踪到。对，我不喜欢这种想法——万一有一天我因为手机一直开着定位而被诬陷犯了重罪怎么办。所以各位，我只是需要让你们知道，我真的需要那部座机，
because my cell phone is not pinpointing my location. And now listen, I don't know if it can still ping. Like when you use it, maybe it pings the towers. I'm gonna need to look into this, but my mind has been on fire ever since I brought it up. My kids just did mock trial at school. They learn a trial and then they go in front of a real judge and they try a case.
因为我的手机可不会精确定位我的位置。而且听着，我不知道它是不是还能被信号塔ping到。比如你使用它的时候，可能还是会连接到基站。我得研究一下这个，但自从我提起这事之后，我的大脑就一直在高速运转。我的孩子们刚刚在学校参加了模拟法庭。他们学习审判流程，然后去真正的法官面前审理一个案件。
And their case, there was a murder in a hotel. Did they use the cell phone pings? The investigators used the cell phone pings and they did a radius that the defense thought was too broad and they contested it and got it expunged so that the jurors never even heard about what cell phones were there. Okay. But the radius was really big. It covered the hotel, the street corner.
在他们的案子里，发生了一起酒店谋杀案。他们用了手机定位数据吗？调查人员使用了手机定位数据，他们划定了一个半径，而辩方认为这个半径范围太广了，于是他们提出了异议并将其作废，所以陪审团甚至根本没听到关于当时有哪些手机信号的数据。好吧。但那个半径其实非常大。它覆盖了酒店和街角。
Like it was really big and they had everyone's cell phone information from that area. Now I think you have to turn on airplane mode to stop the pings. But then you can't get calls. I know. You should get a beeper and a landline just like me. Yeah, because then you'll know my location if I'm at home and you can't fright me for a crime. That's right.
范围真的很大，他们掌握了那个区域里所有人的手机信息。现在我觉得你必须开启飞行模式才能阻止信号追踪。但那样你就接不到电话了。我知道。你应该像我一样弄个寻呼机和一部座机。对，因为那样的话，如果我在家，你就能知道我的位置，也就没法诬陷我犯罪了。没错。
And if someone really needs to get ahold of you, they can call you and type something in for your beeper and then you can read your beeper and then you can drive to a phone somewhere and call that person back. That sounds convenient and really easy to fit into my lifestyle as I know it today. Yeah.
如果真有人需要联系你，他们可以打电话给你，在你的寻呼机上输入一些内容，然后你就可以看寻呼机，接着你可以开车到某个有电话的地方给那个人回电话。这听起来既方便又非常容易融入我当下的日常生活方式。对。
All right, back on topic. Cause there's pay phones everywhere, not there's no pay phones anymore. Good luck finding a pay phone. Should we move on? Yes. All right. Next stop, pies. What? Should we move on? Yes. All right.
好了，言归正传。因为到处都有公用电话——不对，现在已经没有公用电话了。想找个公用电话祝你好运吧。我们该继续前行了吗？对。好吧。下一站，派。什么？我们该继续前行了吗？对。好吧。
Next stop. Pies. Kevin is really worried that they are not going to make it on time. Laverne closes at five, which is only 20 minutes from now. Kevin is all of a sudden a math genius. Yeah. All of a sudden Kevin's like, if we drive this fast in this many minutes, then we'll make the pie. And Angela's like, wait, you're suddenly, you can do math as long as it applies to pies?
下一站，派。凯文真的很担心他们无法准时赶到。拉弗恩派店五点关门，而现在距离那时只有20分钟了。凯文突然成了数学天才。是啊。凯文突然说，如果我们以这个速度行驶这么分钟，那我们就能买到派了。安吉拉就说，等等，你突然之间，只要跟派有关你就会算数学了？
Yeah. Oscar switches the scenario and changes it to salad, and then Kevin can't do the math. We got fan mail about this. First off, we have a compliment from Lizette A. in Houston, Texas, who says, I love this pie joke from Oscar when he pulls out the calculator and asks Kevin to do math. Super smart for whoever wrote that. But Jacob O. from Seattle, Washington has a counterpoint. Jacob is a mathematician. Uh-oh. Jacob says this has bothered me for years, and every time I watch this episode, I am irritated by this. Oh no!
对啊。奥斯卡转换了情境，把它换成沙拉，然后凯文就不会算数学了。我们为此收到了粉丝来信。首先，德克萨斯州休斯顿的利塞特·A.给我们发来了一条赞美，她说：“我太喜欢奥斯卡这个关于派的玩笑了，当时他掏出计算器让凯文算数学。写出这个桥段的人真是太聪明了。”但华盛顿州西雅图的雅各布·O.提出了不同的观点。雅各布是一位数学家。噢，不！
Oh no! At 13 minutes and 38 seconds when Oscar asks Kevin, how much is 19,154 pies divided by 61 pies, and Kevin answers 314 pies? While the number is correct, the answer should not be in units of pi's. The quotient of two quantities which have the same units is unitless, so the answer is just 314, not 314 pi's.
噢，不！在13分38秒时，当奥斯卡问凯文：“19,154个派除以61个派等于多少？”而凯文回答：“314个派？”虽然数字是对的，但答案不应该带有“派”这个单位。两个相同单位的量相除是没有单位的，所以答案应该只是314，而不是314个派。
However, Jacob says it gets worse. Oh no! Pies come with their own canonical division problem. Oscar should have asked, how much is 19,154 pies divided among 61 people? Huh. Yeah. Jacob, you've given us a lot to think about. Yeah. Jacob would like to know, why did the writers have Kevin attach the wrong units? Why did they decide to divide pies by pies instead of dividing pies among people? Jacob, I can tell you right now, there wasn't a mathematician in that room and they should have called one. Yeah, you're right. But I see Jacob's point because Oscar is a
然而，雅各布说情况更糟糕。噢，不！派本身就有它自己的规范除法问题。奥斯卡本该问：“19,154个派分给61个人，每人分到多少？”哈。是啊。雅各布，你让我们陷入了深深的思考。对。雅各布想知道，为什么编剧会让凯文加上错误的单位？为什么他们决定用派去除以派，而不是把派分给人们？雅各布，我现在就可以告诉你，那个房间里当时没有数学家，他们本该叫一个来的。对，你说得对。但我明白雅各布的意思，因为奥斯卡是个
mathematician, so Oscar would have asked the question correctly. He would have phrased it correctly. Yeah. Yes. It's true. He would have caught that, Jacob. That was a good catch. It was a good catch. Lizette, you are still allowed to love this scene. I have a catch for this scene as well. It has nothing to do with mathematics.
数学家，所以奥斯卡会把问题问对的。他会用正确的表述方式来问。是的。没错。确实如此。他会发现这一点的，雅各布。你抓得很准。抓得很准。利塞特，你依然可以喜欢这个场景。我对这个场景也有个发现。它跟数学毫无关系。
Does it have to do with Meredith's screen? At 13 minutes and 45 seconds, Kate had been playing solitaire. I saw it too. I love it that her character is so committed to Solitaire. She gets on this work bus and just plays Solitaire all day. Well now Dwight is going to inform everyone that they're almost out of gas anyway. He refuses to get gas and then he climbs up through the sunroof and is going to go sulk on the top of the bus.
这跟梅勒迪斯的屏幕有关吗？在13分45秒时，凯特一直在玩纸牌游戏。我也看到了。我太喜欢她的角色对纸牌游戏如此执着了。她上了这辆工作巴士，结果一整天都在玩纸牌游戏。好了，现在德怀特要通知大家，他们的油快用完了。他拒绝去加油，然后他爬上天窗，打算去巴士顶上生闷气。
Because he's on the top of the roof, they now cannot safely drive away. Even though Phyllis says just drive away. Yeah, Phyllis. Pam is now going to say, Jim, just go check on him. Just something's up. Go check on him. Yeah, you know, in the Table Read draft of this episode, when we all sat down to read this as a cast,
因为他在车顶上，所以他们现在无法安全地把车开走。尽管菲莉丝说直接开走就行。没错，菲莉丝。帕姆现在要说了：“吉姆，去看看他怎么回事。肯定有点不对劲。去看看他。”对啊，你知道的，在这个剧集的桌读剧本草稿里，当我们所有人坐在一起作为演员阵容进行剧本围读时，
this was actually a scene between Dwight and Pam. Pam was going to go up on the roof and check on Dwight. But after the table read, we had a big discussion about how we thought that it might play better as a Jim Dwight moment. I agree with that, actually. I do too. This is something I haven't shared yet, but since me, John, Rain and Ed were producers this season, something that we now did was we would stay after the table reads for the note sessions. And so this was something I remembered was that, oh yeah, it was decided in the note session that this would change from Dwight and Pam to Dwight and Jim. Oh, oh! Also, before we go on the roof, Angela, I have to note at the end of this scene, Andy's really mad that
这其实是德怀特和帕姆之间的一场戏。原本是帕姆要上屋顶去查看德怀特的状况。但在桌读之后，我们进行了深入的讨论，觉得如果把它改成吉姆和德怀特的时刻，效果可能会更好。其实我也这么认为。我也是。这是我之前没分享过的一件事，但由于我和约翰、雷恩还有埃德这季都是制片人，我们现在会做的一件事是，在桌读结束后留下来开剧本意见会议。所以我记得的就是这个：哦对了，就是在意见会议上决定把这场戏从德怀特和帕姆改成德怀特和吉姆。哦，哦！还有，在我们上屋顶之前，安吉拉，我必须提一下，在这场戏的结尾，安迪真的很生气，因为
they're not going to get pie because it probably means he's not gonna get banana cream because it's the first to go. And then he swishes his curtain. It's the same as the one in our studio. Oh, the same shower curtain. It looks exactly the same. It's like a shower curtain on the top and the bottom,
他们吃不到派了，因为这很可能意味着他吃不到香蕉奶油派了，因为那是卖得最快的。然后他拉了一下他的帘子。这跟我们工作室里的那个一模一样。哦，一样的浴帘。看起来一模一样。就像顶部和底部是浴帘，
but then in the middle, it's like a plastic see-through thing. A clear patch. So everybody, if you wonder what our shower curtain thing looks like in the middle, it's like a plastic see-through thing. A clear patch? So everybody, if you wonder what our shower curtain thing looks like in our studio, it looks like what Andy has on the work bus. You know what? I'm gonna do a side by side.
但在中间，就像是一个塑料的透明部分。一个透明补丁。所以大家，如果你想知道我们工作室里的浴帘中间是什么样子的，它就像是一个塑料的透明部分。一个透明补丁？所以大家，如果你想知道我们在工作室里的浴帘是什么样子的，它看起来就像安迪在工作巴士上的那个一样。你知道吗？我要做一个对比图。
Oh, great! I wanted to tell you guys that this heart to heart that Jim and Dwight have on top of the bus was much longer in the shooting draft. And let me tell you, Jim really lays into Dwight. This is how it was written. Jim climbs up on top of the roof. He gently says, Dwight, Dwight, yeah.
太棒了！我想告诉大家的是，吉姆和德怀特在巴士顶上进行的那次掏心掏肺的谈话，在拍摄剧本里要长得多。而且我得告诉你，吉姆把德怀特狠狠数落了一番。剧本里是这样写的：吉姆爬上车顶。他温和地说：“德怀特，德怀特，行了。”
Jim says, why do you have to be such a cheap prick? You've got four sources of income, a farm, a bed and breakfast, your job, and you own the building. You've got no dependence. I spend every penny on freaking diapers and all I wanted was to buy my wife a pie. With everything you've got,
吉姆说：“你为什么非得这么小气抠门？你有四份收入来源，一个农场，一家住宿加早餐旅馆，你的工作，而且你还拥有这栋大楼。你没有家属要养。我把每一分钱都花在了该死的尿不湿上，而我唯一的愿望就是给我妻子买个派。凭你拥有的这一切，
you couldn't throw me a little bone? Wow. I know, he calls him a cheap prick. Dwight responds and says, hey idiot, you're the one who's rich and you don't even appreciate it. I'm barren. And then Jim
你就不能施舍我一点吗？”哇。我知道，他叫他小气鬼。德怀特回应道：“嘿，白痴，有钱的是你，而你根本不懂得珍惜。我是个不育的人。”然后吉姆
says, what? And the scene continues as it aired. And then Jim tells him that was a prank. Yes. And then Dwight says, well, prank or no prank, I'm still barren. Mm-hmm. Well, Steve Burgess said it was kind of complicated to shoot these two guys up on the top of a bus, as you can imagine. They had rain harnessed to the top of the bus, but they couldn't harness in John because he had to climb up and move around.
说：“什么？”接着剧情就按播出的那样继续了。然后吉姆告诉他那只是个恶作剧。是的。然后德怀特说：“好吧，管它是不是恶作剧，我还是不育的。”嗯哼。好吧，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说过，把这两个家伙弄到巴士顶上去拍摄其实挺复杂的，你可以想象得到。他们在雷恩身上绑了安全带固定在车顶上，但他们没法把约翰绑起来，因为他必须爬上去并四处走动。
So John's just walking around on top of a bus and then they had our camera operators, Matt and Sarah, were up on ladders to make them as high as the bus. Very tricky shot. Well, we learned a little bit of that kind of on top of the bus footage in speed. We sure did. If you are gonna shoot anything on a bus
所以约翰只是在一辆巴士顶上走来走去，然后我们的摄影师马特和萨拉，他们站在梯子上，好让高度和巴士齐平。非常棘手的镜头。好吧，我们在《生死时速》里多多少少也学到了一点这种巴士顶上的镜头经验。我们确实学到了！如果你打算在巴士上
or on top of a bus, you might wanna give us a call because we can help you map it out. We sure can. Well, Nelly and Erin have finished her adoption forms. Nelly's gonna walk up to Andy and ask him to sign it for her. And he says it's unsignable and he wishes her luck with her impossible dream. Erin watches all of this and it really hits her hard.
或者在巴士顶上拍摄任何镜头，你可能想给我们打个电话，因为我们可以帮你规划好。我们当然可以！好吧，奈莉和艾琳已经填好了她的领养表格。奈莉走向安迪，请他帮她签个字。而他说这根本没法签，并祝她好运去实现她那不可能的梦想。艾琳目睹了这一切，这深深地触动了她。
Yeah. We're gonna hear some crying at the front of the bus and Andy assumes it's Nelly and he's kind of ready to go Shame her about it. Yeah, he says British women are famously over-emotional and Pete says It's not Nelly Very pointedly. Yeah, and it's revealed that it's Aaron who's crying While Nelly consoles her saying listen, it's not your fault. It's not your fault.
对。我们听到巴士前部传来了哭声，安迪以为那是奈莉，他正准备去因此羞辱她一番。是的，他说英国女人出了名的情绪过剩，而皮特说：“那不是奈莉。”语气非常明确。是的，然后大家发现哭的人其实是艾琳，而奈莉则在一旁安慰她说：“听着，这不是你的错。这不是你的错。”
Brent shared with us a little bit about the scene and about how they filmed Ellie crying and we want you to hear it. There's a scene at the end of work bus where Ellie Kemper has to cry. I was on set with Brian Cranston when Ellie came up to him and said, hey, I just want you to know as an actress, I cannot cry on cue.
布伦特跟我们分享了一点关于这场戏的事情，以及他们是如何拍摄艾利哭泣的，我们想让你们听听。“在《工作巴士》的结尾有一场戏，艾莉·肯珀必须哭出来。当时我和布莱恩·克兰斯顿在一起，艾利走到他面前说：‘嘿，我想让你知道，作为一名演员，我无法做到一秒落泪。’”
And Brian said to her, it's actually a lot easier than you think. And he told her about how he had been a soap opera actor on this show, Loving, in the 1980s. And he would see the soap opera actresses when they had to cry in a scene. They would drink two liters of water in the morning. And Brian said that if you were hyper hydrated
布莱恩对她说：“这其实比你想象的要容易得多。”他跟她讲了自己在20世纪80年代是如何在肥皂剧《相爱》中担任演员的。每当肥皂剧女演员们在戏里需要哭的时候，他就会看到她们在早晨喝下两升水。布莱恩说，如果你处于超级水合状态，
and you just got sad, the water would pour out of your eyes. Now, I don't know if Ellie took his advice and I don't know if she cries real tears in that scene, but if she did, it's the first time Ellie Kemper ever cried on camera. And it's all thanks to Brian Cranston and the soap opera actresses of loving.
而且你刚好变得伤心，水就会从你的眼睛里涌出来。现在，我不知道艾利有没有听取他的建议，我也不知道她在那个场景里流的是不是真眼泪，但如果她流了，那将是艾莉·肯珀在镜头前第一次哭泣。这一切都要归功于布莱恩·克兰斯顿和《相爱》剧组的肥皂剧女演员们。
Well, Angie I traded some text messages with Ellie Kemper about this. What did she say? Is that why she peed? Cause she was drinking so much water all day. She had a full bladder. She said she did not take this advice. Oh, she used a menthol stick.
好吧，安吉，我跟艾莉·肯珀就这事发过一些短信。她说什么了？这就是她尿裤子的原因吗？因为她一整天都在喝那么多水。她膀胱都满了。她说她根本没听从这个建议。哦，她用的是薄荷棒。
Oh, well that will make your eyes water. I've used them. It's like they dab menthol stick. Oh, well, that will make your eyes water. I've used them. It's like they dab menthol up by your eyes and it makes them water. And then you, you know, you just kind of, yeah, with your voice and, and yours, you know, and then the menthol does the tears. Kenneth Paul, who did my makeup on the show once asked me if I was a vampire. Why? Because he put the menthol in the corner of my eyes and my eyes didn't react to it at all.
哦，那会让你的眼睛流泪的。我用过。就像是他们把薄荷棒点在……哦，那会让你的眼睛流泪的。我用过。就像是他们把薄荷棒点在你的眼角附近，它就会让眼睛流泪。然后你，你知道的，你就会发出那种声音，然后薄荷就起到了催泪的作用。肯尼斯·保罗，曾在剧里负责我的化妆，有一次问我是不是吸血鬼。为什么？因为他把薄荷抹在我的眼角，而我的眼睛对它一点反应也没有。
Do vampires not cry? I don't know. He just was like, are you the walking dead? I can't. He said, I've never seen anyone not have a reaction to the menthol stick. Do your eyes water when you cut onions? Yes. Oh, I know.
吸血鬼不会哭吗？我不知道。他只是觉得：你是行尸走肉吗？我真是服了。他说：我从来没见过谁对薄荷棒没有反应。你切洋葱的时候眼睛会流泪吗？会的。哦，我知道。
So maybe that's how we make you cry in your next project. I guess I'm gonna have to roll in with a bunch of onions. I love this visual. I love the sautéa. If I get a job on a soap opera, I'm like, one second, let me chop an onion. Jim is gonna convince Dwight that he has a lot of children and they are his work children.
所以也许这就是我们在你下一个项目中让你哭泣的方法。我想我得带着一堆洋葱出场了。我喜欢这个画面。我喜欢这种炒洋葱的感觉。如果我在肥皂剧里找到工作，我就会说：等一下，让我切个洋葱。吉姆要说服德怀特，他有很多孩子，他们是他的工作之子。
They are his build-in kinder. And there's something he can do for his building kinder and it's get them some pie. Yep. Dwight is inspired by this. We did have a tiny catch from Allison Y and Louisville, Kentucky, who said, I've been waiting for this little background catch.
他们是他的建筑之子。有些事是他可以为他的建筑之子做的，那就是给他们买些派。是的。德怀特深受此启发。我们确实收到了来自肯塔基州路易斯维尔的艾莉森·Y.的一个细小发现，她说：“我一直在等待这个小小的背景彩蛋。”
The office staff are upset that the pie stand closes at five and it's already 442 When Jim climbs onto the roof to go after Dwight. However, if you look at the watch on Jim's wrist, it actually says 255 It's true. You can see Jim's watch very clearly at 15 minutes 42 seconds 17 minutes 24 seconds And the best shot of it is at 18 minutes, two seconds, and it is 255. Well, here it is, folks. Our almost death number one, when Dwight comes down from the roof and gets behind the wheel and starts speeding away toward the pie. Where do we even start? First of all, we rehearsed the scene, and Rain was actually going to be pretending to drive, but not driving.
办公室员工们对派摊五点关门感到很沮丧，而当吉姆爬上屋顶去追德怀特时，时间已经是4点42分了。然而，如果你看吉姆手腕上的手表，上面显示的时间其实是2点55分。确实如此。你在15分42秒、17分24秒都能非常清楚地看到吉姆的手表，而最好的镜头是在18分02秒，上面显示是2点55分。好吧，各位，这就是我们的“差点丧命”事件第一号，当时德怀特从屋顶下来，坐到方向盘后面，开始加速朝派店开去。我们该从哪里开始说呢？首先，我们排练了这个场景，而雷恩其实只是假装在开车，并不是真的在开。
Yeah, the bus was hooked up to a pull rig. Yes. And off camera, they were going to yell, swerve right. And the whole cast would all lurch to the right. Then they'd say, swerve left. We'd all lurch to the left. But in fact, we were just driving along straight. Yes. And we were not even driving. We were being pulled. Very safe. Very safe.
对，巴士被钩在了一个牵引装置上。是的。而在镜头外，他们会喊：“向右急转弯。”然后整个剧组都会向右倾斜。接着他们会喊：“向左急转弯。”我们就会全体向左倾斜。但事实上，我们只是在笔直地向前开。是的。而且我们根本没在开车。我们是被拖着走的。非常安全。非常安全。
Yes. Well, they watched that in playback and guess what? It looked real phony. Super fakie. We didn't do a really good job, I guess, of fake swerving. So they said, you know what? We're gonna take the bus off the rig. We're gonna put a stunt driver in, rain, you hop out. Now we're going to drive down the road and when we yell swerve right, the stunt driver is going to swerve right.
是的。好吧，他们回放了那个镜头，你猜怎么着？看起来太假了。超级虚假。我们大概没有把假装急转弯演得很好。所以他们说：“你知道吗？我们要把巴士从牵引装置上卸下来。我们要换上特技司机，雷恩，你下来。现在我们要开着车沿着路开，当我们喊向右急转弯时，特技司机就会向右急转弯。”
Yeah. And we should just naturally react. Right. What no one thought about was that there were hundreds of items inside a tiny bus and all of them were not nailed down. They weren't tied down. Everything you see was loose. Rolling chairs, desk lamps, staplers, water cooler, a hoppy pot. None of it was taped down, nailed down, strapped down. None of it. And literally no one thought of this.
对。而我们只需要做出自然的反应。没错。没有人想到的是，一辆小小的巴士里面有成百上千件物品，而且它们都没有被钉牢。它们没有被绑好。你看到的每一样东西都是散落的。滚轮椅、台灯、订书机、饮水机、热饮壶。没有一样东西是用胶带粘住、钉死或绑紧的。什么都没有。而且真的没有人想到这一点。
None of us. I don't know what was up. And then we start off down the road. And when they told the stunt driver to swerve, he swerved like, I thought the bus was going to tip over. It was like such a hard turn. It was so intense, and the entire cast and all of the contents of the bus went flying into the
我们谁都没想到。我不知道是怎么回事。然后我们开始沿着路往前开。当他们告诉特技司机急转弯时，他猛地一转，我当时以为巴士要翻了。那是一个极其剧烈的转弯，简直太猛烈了，整个剧组以及巴士里的所有东西都飞向了
side of the bus. And you can see it in real time because that's the take we used. They used a very tiny portion of the take because we were on the floor covered in things. Covered in people. Covered in people. You couldn't even see Creed. He was covered with so many things. And people. in people. Covered in people. You couldn't even see Creed. He was covered with so many things. And people.
巴士的一侧。你可以实时看到这一幕，因为我们用的就是那个镜头。他们只用了那个镜头非常小的一部分，因为当时我们全都倒在地板上，被各种东西盖住了。被人群盖住了。被人群盖住了。你甚至都看不到克里德了。他被那么多的东西给盖住了。还有人。还有人。被人群盖住了。你甚至都看不到克里德了。他被那么多的东西给盖住了。还有人。
And people. I hurt my knee because who was it? Was it Clark's chair rolled into my chair? I rolled, everything, I got smushed up against the wall. Everything rolled into me. Yes. My lamp slid into my lap. I remember catching my lamp in my lap.
还有人。我的膝盖受伤了，因为那是谁的？是克拉克的椅子滚进我的椅子里了吗？我滚了，一切都发生了，我被挤压到了墙上。所有的东西都朝我滚了过来。是的。我的台灯滑到了我的大腿上。我还记得我把台灯接在大腿上。
Yeah, I was on the ground. Leslie was on top of me. And I remember we had to pull a lot of things out to find Phyllis. She heard her ankle. Our camera operators. Yes, they went flying. They went flying while holding cameras, 80-pound cameras. Yes.
对，我当时倒在地上。莱斯利压在我身上。我记得我们不得不搬开很多东西才找到菲莉丝。她的脚踝受伤了。我们的摄影师。是的，他们飞出去了。他们手里拿着摄像机飞了出去，那是80磅重的摄像机。是的。
And true to their love of their cameras and the equipment, you know, they used their bodies to shield the cameras. The bus was an absolute mess. It was like someone picked it up and shook it in the air and everything went everywhere. I mean, I'm thinking back to it. We stopped the bus and we were just in a daze. Yeah, we got off the side of the road. I don't even remember where we were just in a daze. Yeah. We got off the side of the road. I don't even remember where we were.
出于对他们手中的摄像机和设备的真爱，你知道的，他们用自己的身体去保护摄像机。巴士里真是一团糟。就像有人把它拿起来在空中摇晃了一番，然后所有的东西四处乱飞。我是说，回想起来。我们把巴士停了下来，当时整个人都处于恍惚状态。对，我们把车开到了路边。我甚至都不记得我们当时在哪儿了，整个人都在恍惚中。对，我们把车停到了路边。我甚至都不记得我们当时在哪儿了。
We couldn't even get off very quickly because they had to like kind of pull us out of it all. Yes. The medics came rushing up. We were able to assess that everyone was, you know, had bumps and bruises but were ultimately okay. But shook up, I think is a fair assessment. There were some bathrooms nearby. We were like in a random park. Yeah. And I remember there
我们甚至无法很快下车，因为他们不得不把我们从那堆东西里拉出来。是的。医护人员匆忙赶来。我们得以确认每个人都，你知道的，受了些磕磕碰碰，但最终并无大碍。不过受到惊吓是肯定的，我觉得这样形容很恰当。附近有几个洗手间。我们好像在一个随意的公园里。是的，我记得有
were like these hikers coming back from a hike. I just remember the look on their face because they were just watching the cast of the office walking in a daze to the public restroom. I went in there with Phyllis. They got ice for Phyllis, I remember. Yep, my knee was a little messed up. We couldn't believe it. We were like, wow, wow.
那些远足回来的人。我只记得他们脸上的表情，因为他们眼睁睁看着办公室的演员们神情恍惚地走向公共洗手间。我跟菲莉丝一起进去了。我记得他们给菲莉丝拿了冰袋。对，我的膝盖有点不太舒服。我们简直不敢相信。我们当时感叹：哇，哇。
That just happened. Yes. They had to reset the whole interior of the bus. Yeah, we took a lunch break. Yeah, we were like, forget it, let's go to lunch. And we couldn't even ride back to our base interior of the bus. Yeah, we took a lunch break. Yeah, we were like, forget it, let's go to lunch. And we couldn't even ride back to our base camp in the bus, which had been the intention, so they had to bring all these vans. But we got back, we had lunch, we were like, we're okay, we kind of ended up laughing about it. We were like, oh my god, that's crazy. We're like,
刚才居然发生了那种事。是的。他们不得不重新布置巴士的整个内部。对，我们去吃了午饭。是的，我们当时想：算了吧，去吃午饭吧。而且我们甚至不能坐巴士回我们的基地……对，我们去吃了午饭。是的，我们当时想：算了吧，去吃午饭吧。而且我们甚至不能坐巴士回我们的基地营，原本是打算坐的，所以他们不得不调来所有的这些面包车。但我们回去了，吃了午饭，我们想：我们没事，最后我们甚至还拿这事开起了玩笑。我们说：“哦天哪，太疯狂了。我们就像是，”
Brian Cranston, you almost killed the whole cast of the office. Ha ha ha. But we're okay. Yes, and you know, he had had a number of crazy things happen on that RV and Breaking Bad, where it's like, you know, going back and forth and all of the meth lab is flying all over the place. So we're just trading crazy stories. He felt really bad though. He did. He was so sweet.
“布莱恩·克兰斯顿，你差点害死了办公室的整个剧组。哈哈哈哈。”不过我们没事。是的，你知道的，他在《绝命毒师》里那辆房车上也遇到过不少疯狂的事，比如，车子前后颠簸，冰毒实验室的东西到处乱飞。所以我们只是在交换彼此疯狂的故事。不过他确实感到很内疚。他真的很内疚。他太暖心了。
I mean, we cannot express enough how sweet Brian Grinston is. But it was right. We're like, it's fine. It's fine. And after lunch, we had some more scenes to shoot on the bus. They had gotten it all put back together and they brought us together and they said, guys, we're so sorry about what happened. But we have kind of an exciting announcement.
我是说，我们怎么强调布莱恩·克兰斯顿有多暖心都不为过。但这是对的。我们当时说：没关系。没关系。午饭过后，我们在巴士上还有一些场景要拍。他们已经把车内重新收拾好了，把我们召集到一起说：“伙计们，对于发生的事我们深表歉意。但我们有个令人兴奋的好消息。”
We know it's just been hot and miserable on this bus, but we have found a portable air conditioning unit. Yeah, we could hook it up to the back of the bus. We're gonna like tow it on like a little trailer behind us. And it'll have a tube that comes in the top vent and it's silent. Yeah, we can keep it on the whole shoot, the whole rest of the day. Amazing. Yes, it's silent. Yeah, we can keep it on the whole shoot, the whole rest of the day.
“我们知道在这辆巴士上一直又热又难受，但我们找到了一台便携式空调。”对，我们可以把它挂在巴士后面。我们要把它像个小拖车一样拖在我们身后。它会有一根管子伸进顶部的通风口，而且它是静音的。是的，我们可以让它在整个拍摄过程中一直开着，一整天都开着。太棒了。是的，它是静音的。是的，我们可以让它在整个拍摄过程中一直开着，一整天都开着。
Amazing. Yes, it's clean. We don't have any more crazy driving stunts. We're just gonna drive and capture the last few scenes. It's gonna be great. And it's so excited. So excited, we got on the bus. There was such this cool air.
太棒了。是的，很干净。我们再也不会有任何疯狂的特技驾驶了。我们只要开车并拍完最后几个镜头就行了。一切都会好起来的。大家都很兴奋。怀着兴奋的心情，我们上了巴士。车里吹着如此凉爽的风。
Oh, it felt like a retreat from the heat, the minute you walked in. It was right above where I was sitting. The vent. The vent. Yes. So I was like so happy. This is great. You got that nice cold air blowing on you.
哦，一走进车里，那种感觉就像是从酷热中逃离到了世外桃源。它就在我坐的那个位置正上方。通风口。通风口。是的。所以我当时超级高兴。这太棒了。有那么好的冷风吹在你身上。
Ah, well, as we start filming, Jenna started to say, I smell something. Something smells weird. And we were like, nah, I don't smell it. I was at the front of the bus. And we were like, I don't smell it. I was at the front of the bus. I remember being like, I don't smell anything. And you did have a lot of allergies. I did.
啊，好吧，当我们开始拍摄时，詹娜开始说：“我闻到什么味儿了。闻起来怪怪的。”然后我们说：“没有啊，我没闻到。”我当时在巴士前部。然后我们说：“我没闻到。我当时在巴士前部。”我记得当时觉得：我什么都没闻到。而你确实有很多过敏症。我确实有。
I was, you know, I was always noticing dust. I can probably spot mold like a mile away. Yeah. It starts to stink. So we were kind of like, well, Jenna's a little sensitive to things, you know. I was like, guys, it smells like gas. Yeah. It smells, I feel like it's, I can smell exhaust.
我当时，你知道的，我总是对灰尘很敏感。我可能隔老远就能察觉到霉味。是的。开始发臭了。所以我们当时有点觉得，好吧，詹娜对这些东西有点敏感，你知道的。我当时说：“伙计们，闻起来有瓦斯味。”是的。闻起来，我觉得，我能闻到尾气味。
Yeah. Something is wrong. Something is wrong. And Jenna was like, I'm serious. Something is, there's gas guys coming in. And then I remember Sarah, our camera operator, she got like dizzy. Yeah. She was like, guys, I don't feel good.
是的。有哪里不对劲。有哪里不对劲。然后詹娜说：“我是认真的。有什么不对劲，有毒气进来了，伙计们。”然后我记得我们的摄影师萨拉，她开始觉得头晕了。是的。她说：“伙计们，我觉得很不舒服。”
She was standing right behind you, right under the vent. Yes. So then Brian Cranston comes on the bus, he gets a chair, he pulls it over and he stands on the chair and puts his face right up in that vent and immediately goes, oh my God, everyone get off the bus. Here's what was going on. That air conditioner that we were pulling behind the bus, the intake tube was about
她当时就站在你身后，正对着那个通风口下方。是的。然后布莱恩·克兰斯顿上了巴士，他拿了把椅子，拉过来站在椅子上，把脸直接凑到那个通风口前，立刻说道：“哦天哪，所有人马上离开巴士。”当时的情况是这样的。我们拖在巴士后面的那台空调，它的进气管距离
a foot away from the exhaust pipe of the bus. We were literally sucking it in, making it cooler, and shooting it back in the bus. Yes. We were breathing in the bus's exhaust. Carbohydrate monoxide. Yes. 100%. We were breathing in the busses exhaust. Carbon monoxide. Yes. 100%.
巴士的排气管只有大约一英尺远。我们实际上是在把尾气吸进去，把它冷却，然后再喷回到巴士里。是的。我们在吸入巴士的尾气。一氧化碳。是的。100%百分之百。我们在吸入巴士的尾气。一氧化碳。是的。100%百分之百。
I remember Leslie's eyes were red and watery. And Sarah got this horrible headache. You were like feeling almost nauseous, right? Yes. Yes. Which again, we assumed was just my car sickness. Yeah. Right?
我记得莱斯利的眼睛红红的，还含着泪水。萨拉则头痛欲裂。你当时甚至感觉有点反胃，对吧？是的。是的。而我们再次以为那只是我的晕车症。是的。对吧？
I remember the look of horror on Brian's face. It feels so bad for him. He immediately was like, everyone off the bus now. We had been breathing in carbon monoxide. For a good amount of time. Yeah. Oh. So we all got off the bus. The medics came over.
我记得布莱恩脸上惊恐的表情。他为自己感到非常内疚。他立刻喊道：“所有人立刻下巴士。”我们一直在吸入一氧化碳。持续了相当长的一段时间。是的。噢。所以我们都下了巴士。医护人员赶了过来。
They checked us out. They said we were all okay, that our exposure time would not put us at great risk. They mentioned we might have some headaches, but that we would ultimately be fine. And luckily, the scene we had not shot yet is the scene coming up, which is the pie. Pie's. If we all look like we couldn't be happier to be eating the pie, it's because we were really happy to be eating the pie. And breathing fresh air.
他们给我们做了检查。他们说我们都没事，我们的吸入时间不会让我们面临巨大的风险。他们提到我们可能会有些头痛，但最终会没事的。幸运的是，我们还没拍的场景就是接下来要拍的那个——吃派。派。如果我们看起来没有比吃派更高兴的了，那是因为我们吃派的时候确实很高兴。而且呼吸到了新鲜空气。
After this day we had, yes, after almost dying twice, this pie was so delicious. And listen, our characters are happy to be eating pie as well, because Andy is going to give Nelly the signed application form. Kevin is going to get Oscar to throw pie in his face. Yeah. Pam tells Jim she is so happy to be eating pie and he's so happy that he's made her happy. I want you to know in the table read draft of the script,
经历了这样的一天之后，是的，在差点死了两次之后，这个派真是太美味了。而且听着，我们的角色们吃派也很高兴，因为安迪要把签好的申请表交给奈莉了。凯文让奥斯卡把派砸在自己脸上了。是的。帕姆告诉吉姆她吃派吃得太高兴了，而他因为让她开心而感到很高兴。我想让你们知道，在剧本的桌读草稿里，
we did not make it to the pie stand. Oh, that would have been so sad. That's what we said. Me, John, Rain and Ed were like, they need to get pie. In the original version of the script, the only thing we make it to is a gas station, and Dwight brings out hostess pies for everybody. Oh, I'm so glad we made it to Laverne's pies. Tire's also fixed. Tire's fixed also. That place too.
我们并没有去成派摊。哦，那太让人难过了。我们当时就是这么说的。我和约翰、雷恩还有埃德都觉得：他们必须得吃到派。在剧本的最初版本里，我们唯一能到达的地方是一个加油站，德怀特给每个人拿了好时派。哦，我太高兴我们去了拉弗恩派店了。轮胎也修好了。轮胎也修好了。那个地方也是。
Well, we got a question from Tally M in Toronto, Ontario, who said, background catch. While Kevin is trying to convince Oscar to pie him in the face, Erin and Peter chatting. Do you think this is foreshadowing for their future relationship or just a coincidence? Well, actually Tally, there were a few little flirty moments in this whole episode that didn't make it in between Aaron and Pete. There was one when she's filling out the adoption forms with Nelly. They have a little scene and this was another scene that they had where Pete
好吧，我们收到了来自安大略省多伦多市的塔莉·M.的一个问题，她说：“背景彩蛋。当凯文试图说服奥斯卡用派砸他的脸时，艾琳和彼得在聊天。你觉得这是在为他们未来的关系做伏笔，还是纯属巧合？”嗯，其实，塔莉，在这个整集的剧情里，艾琳和彼得之间有几个没有播出的调情小瞬间。其中有一个是她和奈莉一起填领养表格的时候。他们有一小场戏，这是他们拍的另一场戏：彼特
takes a bite of blueberry pie and then he kind of squishes blueberries on his teeth and then he walks up to Aaron and goes, do I have anything in my teeth? And he smiles and his teeth are all blue and they have this cute moment. So they actually had a few scenes together that are just furthering the storyline of Pete being someone that Aaron is really bonding with. I like Pete and Aaron together.
咬了一口蓝莓派，然后他把蓝莓挤在牙齿上，接着他走到艾琳面前说：“我牙齿上有东西吗？”然后他微笑了，牙齿全变成了蓝色，他们有了这个可爱的时刻。所以他们其实一起拍了几场戏，只是为了推进彼得成为一个让艾琳真正产生羁绊的人这条故事线。我挺喜欢彼得和艾琳在一起的。
I do too. A lot. I believe it and I like it. Yeah, there was even a Pete talking head about Aaron in this episode that didn't make it in where he says that Aaron's just a really kind person and she reminds him of his mom. Hmm. Well, I want to share a little Phil Shea story about this pie. This pie was from a place called Simple Things Sandwich Shop and Pie Shop.
我也很喜欢。非常喜欢。我相信而且我很喜欢。是的，这一集里甚至还有一个彼得关于艾琳的单人访谈没有剪进去，他在里面说艾琳真的是个很善良的人，而且她让他想起了自己的妈妈。嗯。好吧，我想分享一个小故事，关于这个派的，来自菲尔·谢伊。这个派来自一个叫“简单事物三明治店与派店”的地方。
And I remember that ahead of shooting this episode, Phil came up to me and asked me what kind of pie I would like to eat. He did. He went to the whole cast. I was allowed to pick anything but rhubarb because Pam doesn't like rhubarb, which is ironic because you love strawberry rhubarb is my favorite. But I ended up picking blueberry. I picked chocolate. Mm-hmm.
我记得在拍摄这一集之前，菲尔走到我面前问我喜欢吃什么口味的派。他确实这么做了。他问了整个剧组。除了大黄派以外，我什么都可以选，因为帕姆不喜欢大黄派，这很讽刺，因为你最喜欢草莓大黄派了。但我最后选了蓝莓。我选了巧克力。嗯哼。
Mm-hmm. Well, now the final scene of this episode is everyone is back at work. They seem exhausted. Andy is going to come out with his banjo and lead everyone in one last roll call chant, and he ends it by playing Flatten Scruggs. Flatten Scruggs was an American bluegrass duo, singer and guitarist Lester Flatt and banjo player Earl Scruggs, both of whom had been members of Bill Monroe's band, The Bluegrass Boys, from 1945 to 1948,
嗯哼。好吧，现在这一集的最后一幕是每个人都回到了工作岗位上。他们看起来筋疲力尽。安迪拿着他的班卓琴出场了，带领大家进行最后一次点名齐唱，最后他以弹奏拉斯特·弗拉特和厄尔·斯克格斯的曲子收尾。拉斯特·弗拉特和厄尔·斯克格斯是一个美国蓝草音乐二人组，歌手兼吉他手拉斯特·弗拉特和班卓琴手厄尔·斯克格斯，两人都曾在1945年至1948年期间担任比尔·门罗乐队“蓝草男孩”的成员，
and then they formed a duo. I loved Ed playing the banjo at the end of this episode, and I feel like we should hear it. But before we do, thank you guys so much for sending in your questions and comments. Thank you, Steve Burgess. Thank you, Ellie Kemper. Brent Forrester.
后来他们组成了二人组。我太喜欢埃德在这一集结尾弹班卓琴了，我觉得我们应该听听看。但在我们听之前，非常感谢大家发来你们的问题和评论。谢谢你，史蒂夫·伯吉斯。谢谢你，艾莉·肯珀。布伦特·福斯特。
We just love you guys so much and thanks for supporting Office Ladies. And now, here's Ed playing the banjo. Roll call. Roll call. Roll call. What? There you have it you guys. That was work bus,
我们真的超级爱你们，谢谢你们支持《办公室女士》。现在，接下来是埃德弹奏班卓琴。点名。点名。点名。什么？你们听到了吧，各位。那是《工作巴士》，
aka death bus. And guess what? Next week, Brian Cranston is going gonna talk all about it. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
又名《死亡巴士》。你们猜怎么着？下周，布莱恩·克兰斯顿将要来聊聊关于这一切的一切。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。
Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的资深制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑与混音工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。